SENATE ON HEALTH WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE
TO BE COVERED BY TEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
ND IT HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES
COMPLIANCE OF THIS ORDER IS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE AND TEN TWENTY ONE- ST IN
THE HEARING ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED.
I ASK THAT ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HE PRESENT IN HEARING
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED SO WE MISSED
OUT SHOULD QUORUM WHEN
APPROPRIATE- IT DIDN'T BEGIN OUR
HEARING AND TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
ABUSING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE ONE
ONE FOUR ZERO FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES THE WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE CAN SENATE INDOOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT.
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL
BE UN MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO TRUST THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. THE TESTIMONY OF THE
PHONE. IS IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. AND
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE ARE AFTER
CONNECTIONS. LAKE NOTE THAT DUE
TO. REGARDING THE LIFE OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. ISAAC COMMITTEE CHAIR
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME.
TO BE DETERMINED BY THE CHAIR
AND HEARING THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
FOR. TESTIMONY IS UP. TWO
MINUTES PER WITNESS FOR MAX TO
WITNESSES. FOR MAXIMO FOUR
MINUTES ON EACH SIDE. ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS INTERNET. AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE MEASURE. WE
HAVE TEN BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
HOWEVER I WOULD NOTE THAT WE
WILL NOT BE HEARING FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB NINE TWENTY THREE
BY CENTER WIENER. WE ALSO HAVE
THREE ITEMS ON OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR TODAY THERE FILE ITEMS
NUMBER THREE. SB NINE THIRTY
FOUR BY CENTER RUBIO. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB NINE SIXTY SEVEN
BY CENTER HERTZBERG. AND ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
THREE BY CENTER PAN MYSELF. FOR
BEFORE YOUR PRESENTATION ON THE
BILLS BUT THE STAFF IS A QUORUM
CONSOLE OBSESSION HERE- WHICH IS
ABOUT. RIGHT CONTROL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
PAN. PAN YES MELENDEZ EGGMAN
YOUR GONZALEZ GROVE HERE FOR
TARO LEYVA LIMON. ROTH YOUR
RUBIO WE WIENER. THE QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED THANK YOU SO NUMBER
NALCO ENOUGH FOLLOW ORDERS SO
FIRST ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
NINE SIXTY FOUR BY CENTER WIENER. WELCOME THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
OUR COLLEAGUES- YOU'RE
PRESENTING SENATE BILL NINE
SIXTY FOUR TO HELP RETAIN AND
EXPAND CALIFORNIA'S OF
STRUGGLING MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE. BUT FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BILL I'M HAPPY
TO- EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT- AS STATED IN THE
ANALYSIS- AND ALSO WE WILL BE
MOVING THIS PRACTICE ANALYSIS
PROVISION IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
COMMITTEE GUIDANCE IN THE POLICY
COMMENTS SO MOVING INTO A
DIFFERENT. AREA OKAY- AND- I
ALSO IS ON THE CLEAR MEMBERS AS
WE KNOW I THINK THIS IS A VERY
IMPACTFUL BILL TERMS OF SHORING
UP IN EXPANDING THE MENTAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE IT'S NOT A
SILVER BULLET THERE IS NO SUCH
THING THERE'S SO MUCH GREAT WORK
HAPPENING- THIS YEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE BIPARTISAN WORK
INCLUDING BY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE GOVERNOR- AND I
KNOW WE- ARE REAL OPPORTUNITY.
TO MOVE THE DIAL THIS YEAR TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT- SO MANY CALIFORNIANS
OF ALL AGES WHO NEED IT. AND
THIS BY IS PART OF THAT SOLUTION
FOCUSING ON THE WORK FORCE- JUST
ONE THIRD OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
LIVE- WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ISSUES RECEIVE THE CARE THEY
NEED TWO THIRDS OF CALIFORNIANS
WHO NEED BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TREATMENT. OR SEATING- ONE OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT. FAILURE IS
THE SHORE OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CARE. WORKERS I TODAY- THIRTY
ONE. WITH A- PUT IN THE AMOUNT
SERVICES REPORT HOW A WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE- OF AND PARTICULARLY
FOR PEOPLE LIVING IN RURAL AREAS
OR IN COMMUNITY- THAT WERE
ENGLISH IS NOT A TYPICALLY THE
FIRST LANGUAGE- AND LGBTQ
COMMUNITIES WE HAD EVEN MORE
ACUTE- UNDER SERVICE IN TERMS OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE- AND- SO
MANY- AND OF COURSE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE- PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUFFERING WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES ARE ON. OUR STREETS
IN OUR JAILS AND HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY ROOMS- OUR STATE'S
STRAIN MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
HONESTLY- WILL BE ON THE VERGE
OF COLLAPSE- AND WE'LL TRY AND
IN A VERY NEGATIVE DIRECTION.
WITHOUT HEALTH CARE WORKERS WITH
GREAT WORK- TO TRY TO SURE
PEOPLE CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE AND
UTILIZE INSURANCE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH CARE PROVIDING FUNDING
FOR MENTAL HEALTH CARE WHETHER
IN OUR SCHOOLS OR ELSEWHERE- BUT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE WORK FORCE.
TO DELIVER. THOSE SERVICES OR
YOU'RE NEVER GONNA WE'RE NEVER
GONNA CHIEF OUR GOALS. I'M
CYNICAL NINE SIXTY FOUR WILL
INCREASE ACCESS TO CRITICAL-
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES- WITH
HOLISTIC SOLUTIONS TO REBUILD
THE WORK FORCE- BY- DURING. THE
FOLLOWING ESTABLISH HIM
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
PRESERVATION AND RESTORATION
FUND. CREATING A STIPEND PROGRAM
FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE PURSUING A
MASTERS IN SOCIAL WORK- WITH A
SPECIALIZED FOCUS ON PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. ARE CREATING
AN ONLINE JOB BOARD WERE
LICENSED PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA
COMPOSED BOB OPENINGS ARE FOR
BEHAVIOR THERE WERE. THE ACCESS
TO CLOSE BECAUSE CARE BY MAKING
SUPPORT SPECIAL A STATE. MEDICAL
BENEFIT INSTEAD OF THE CURRENT
OFTEN AND ESTABLISHING A
STATEWIDE CERTIFYING BODY TO
CERTIFY THESE PEER. SUPPORT
SPECIALIST AMENDING THE EXISTING
MEDICARE GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION CODE THAT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS TO THE LIST OF
THOSE ELIGIBLE UNDER THE
PROGRAM. DEVELOPING XCELERATED
SOCIAL WORK PROGRAMS WITH NEW
COURSEWORK FOCUSED ON BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TO GET NEW AND BETTER AND
EVEN EVEN BETTER TRAINED SOCIAL
WORKERS IN THE FIELD QUICKLY.
REQUIRING A STUDY. CALIFORNIA'S
BUDGET HEALTH LACING
REQUIREMENTS TO ELIMINATE
UNNECESSARY BUREAUCRATIC
BARRIERS THAT KEEP WELL TRAINED
AND TALENTED- BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE WORKERS FROM ENTERING THE
FIELD AND WORKING TO THE FULL
EXTENT OF THEIR SCOPE OF
PRACTICE IN TERMS OF THEIR
EDUCATION. I'M REQUIRING A
COMPREHENSIVE LANDSCAPE ANALYSIS
OF THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE SO THE LONG TERM
POLICY CHANGES AND INVESTMENTS
OR IN CALIFORNIA ACTUAL FIRST
NEEDS. ARE COLLEAGUES THIS BILL
IS A STRONG STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION- AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE- WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY ARE ON ARTS
ROD- I'M- JUST MENTAL STEINBERG
INSTITUTE ONE OF OUR CO
SPONSORS. JONATHAN PORTEUS THE
CEO OF WELL SPACE IN SOCCER.
RIGHT THANK YOU SO WITH UP EARLY
WITNESSES WHO ARE IN THE ROOM
US- SO YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES
OF TOTAL FOUR MINUTES TOGETHER
SO IF YOU RUN OVER TIME WE GET
TO THAT WARNING BUT THEN. THAT
SHORTENS THE TIME FOR SOMETHING
LIKE THIS. WELCOME EMBO EASEMENT
ON BEHALF OF THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE WE'RE AN INDEPENDENT
NON PROFIT PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE. DEDICATED TO
ADVANCING SOUND PUBLIC POLICY
AND INSPIRING LEADERSHIP ON THE
ISSUES OF BRAIN HEALTH AND ARE
AT THE VERY PROUD SPONSORS OF SB
NINE SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME AND THANK YOU
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR WORK
ON THIS BILL IT'S BEEN WONDERFUL
TO WORK WITH YOU. I JUST WANTED
TO GET A HIGHLIGHTING SOMETHING
THAT'S- WE- I MENTIONED EARLIER.
TODAY THIRTY ONE COUNTIES WITH A
HIGH NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES HAVE A WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE. AND BECAUSE OF THAT.
ONLY ONE- ONE THIRD OF THAT
CALIFORNIANS WITH A MENTAL
ILLNESS NOT. THE MISSUS THEY
NEED. BECAUSE OF THE COVERT
NINETY CAN MAKE WE ARE WE-
HEALTHCARE WORKERS RESIGNING IN
DROVES AND MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
SKYROCKETING. AND AS A RESULT
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE HAS GONE FROM CHALLENGE
TO CRISIS. WITHOUT ESSENTIAL
WORKERS TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
CARE SERVICES ARE DROPPING
FACILITIES ARE CLOSING AND THE
SICKEST AMONG US ARE CYCLING
BETWEEN THE STREET JAIL AND
EMERGENCY ROOMS. AND AS WE SINK
DEEPER INTO THIS CRISIS STATE IS
ON THE VERGE OF MONUMENTAL AND
INCREDIBLY NEEDED REFORMS WITH
CATALAN THE USE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE AND THE NINE
EIGHT EIGHT MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
LINE. BUT WE'RE DOING THEM
WITHOUT THE WORK FORCE TO MAKE
IT HAPPEN. IF WE DO NOT TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION TO STABILIZE
OUR WORKFORCE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE UNABLE TO ACCESS CARE
WILL CONTINUE TO DROP. PEOPLE
WILL FALL EVEN SICKER AND IN THE
MOST TRAGIC OF CASES PEOPLE WILL
DIE. LEGISLATION IS A CRITICAL
FIRST STEP TO STABILIZE AND
REBUILD OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. A REVITALIZED
DIVERSIFIED AND EXPANDED WORK
FORCE IS NEEDED TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS GET THE CARE THEY
DESERVE. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. AFTER
FORTY S. WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M DOCTOR JONATHAN PORTIS ON
THE CEO OF WALL SPACE HEALTH
HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO REGION
I'M A LICENSED CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST HEREIN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- I RUN A VERY
LARGE INTEGRATED BEHAVIORAL AND
HEALTH CENTER NETWORK WITH ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PATIENTS I HAVE RUN
MARRIAGE FAMILY THERAPY-
TRAINING PROGRAM IS HELPFUL LPC
. I'M SORRY I AM- HAVE BUILT
UPON OF NEW PROGRAMS AND- ALSO
BE CERTIFICATES PROGRAMS FOR
PEOPLE WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE WE
NEED A WORK FORCE WE ARE
SPREADING FEWER AND FEWER
PEOPLE. ACROSS MORE MORE CLIENTS
AND WE NEED A WORK FORCE IN THIS
BILL WILL HELP US BRING THAT
WORK FOR THE- TROOPS. THAT IS
ALREADY HERE THE TRAINING
PROGRAMS ARE READY FOR PEOPLE-
WE'VE GOT PLENTY OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE PROBABLY LIKELY THAT FOR
TEACHING RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
THEY'VE GOT COMPASSION FATIGUE.
AND THE COVETED- AND I MAKE HAS
REALLY WORN THEM OUT. SO THIS IS
A PERFECT TIME FOR THIS BILL TO
INFUSE OUR TRAINING SYSTEMS WITH
WHAT WHAT THEY NEED. TO BRING
MORE CLINICIANS ONLINE I CON
EMPHASIZE SMALL PROBABLY NOT
BETTER THIS CAN. PLAN HOW. IT IS
AND I DO A- THAT YOU VOTE AYE ON
THIS. THANK YOU FOR MUCH FOR YES
OR NO MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF- S. B. NINE SIXTY
FOUR ARE THERE ANY HERE IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED. SAYING NINE
LET'S MODERATOR- PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SIXTY FOUR NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION ONLY. THE MODERATOR ON
THE LINE.
SOME SIX.
I DID ASK THAT. A LOT. OKAY OKAY
WE CAN'T. PLEASE BYRIDER. I
CAN'T HEAR ANYTHING. OKAY- RIGHT
. SO WITH- WELL WE HAVE NO
FOCUSED WORLD SO WE'RE GONNA FOR
THOSE OF YOU ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE UP PLEASE
JUST HANG IN THERE- WE'RE GOING
TO- BUT THIS MOMENT- LET'S JUST
MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IN THE TELECONFERENCE LINE
PLEASE HOLD ON THERE DON'T DON'T
DROP OFF- WE'RE TRYING TO FIX
THIS WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON BUT LET'S JUST
AND MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION IN
THIS ROOM SO WE DO NOT HAVE
FORMAL OPPOSITION. TEST ARE YOU
REGISTERED HERE ARE THERE ANY
OPPONENTS OF S. B. NINE SIXTY
FOUR WHO WISH TO TESTIFY YOU ARE
HERE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED.
OKAY I'VE SEEN A- OKAY. OKAY
WELL SORRY ALL RIGHT SO I DO NOT
SEE ANYONE- WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION- SO LET'S SEE ARE
WE STILL WAITING TO. ACT ALL
RIGHT- SO WE WILL DO IS WE'LL
TAKE A BRIEF RECESS LIKE FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE TECHNICAL PROBLEM
IS AT THIS POINT ALL RIGHT SO-
THIS COMMITTEE HEARING WILL BE
IN RECESS- FOR A FEW MINUTES
AND- TO A FIGURE OF TELEHEALTH-
COMMENTS FROM THE AREA WELL
TECHNICALLY TO WAIT TILL WE HEAR
BOTH. SO I SINCE WE HAVEN'T
PATTERSON RECESS YET HI I AM
GOING TO. RIGHT I AM GOING TO I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S A MEMBER OF
HE COMMITTEE WHO DOES HAVE A
QUESTION OR COMMENT SHE WISHES
TO MAKE- SO CENTRAL THE AMOUNT.
THANK YOU IN A DAY AT THE
ACCOMMODATION I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I AM SPECIFICALLY
INTERESTED IN THE PORTION OF THE
STUDY THAT REQUIRES THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES. TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR RENEWING THE
LICENSE OF A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL WHO HAS. AN EXPIRED
LICENSE- WE HAVE A CONSTITUENTS
IN MY DISTRICT WHO WAS A
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN.
AND LAST RENEW HER LICENSE IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN. HER HUSBAND
BECAME VERY ILL IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND SHE BECAME
HIS FULL TIME AND PERMANENT CARE
GIVER UNTIL HE PASSED AWAY.
UNFORTUNATELY IT WAS AT THAT
TIME HER CARING FOR HIM THAT SHE
MISSED THE RENEWAL NOTICE FOR
HER LICENSE. AT TO REINSTATE HER
LICENSE THE CONSTITUENT WOULD
HAVE TO START THE PROCESS ALL
OVER AGAIN INCLUDING TAKING
EXAMS AND COMPLETING THREE
THOUSAND OR SUPERVISED HOURS
OVER A HUNDRED FOUR WEEKS. AFTER
HAVING IT LICENSE SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. DESPITE MULTIPLE
CALLS TO THE AGENCY AND
DEPARTMENT FOR ACCOMMODATIONS
FOR EXEMPTIONS NOTHING WAS ABLE
TO BE DONE I AM VERY HOPEFUL
THAT. BECOME FARM BUT THAT IF
NEXT SECTION US SOMETHING TO
THIS EXTREME CASE THAT CAN BE
DOCUMENTED AND APPROVED. AT THAT
THE STUDY TO LOOK AT A PRICES AT
A PROCESS THAT'S DIFFERENT. UP
FOR RENEWING. RESTORING THE
LICENSE PERHAPS THROUGH A
APPEAL A WAIVER DOCUMENTATION
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THE
RISING NEED FOR MORE MENTAL
HEALTH BEHAVIOR. THE CPI. I'M SO
THANKFUL THAT YOU'RE BRING THIS
FORWARD AND WANTED TO JUST
MENTION THIS VERY SPECIFIC CASE-
AND THAT ED CAME FORWARD THIS
YEAR. OKAY THANK YOU CEREMONY
NOW WE ARE STILL WAITING TO HEAR
TEST. OKAY ALL RIGHT SO THAT THE
REST OF MEMBERS THAT MIGHT THE
SCHOOL TRIED TO HEAR THE
TESTIMONY I GAVE THURMOND THE
CHANCE SHE HAD TO LEAVE. SORRY I
HAVE A CELL LET'S- BRING ON
MODERATOR ARE YOU THERE. YES I'M
HERE EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT SO.
LET'S GO LET'S TAKE TESTIMONY ON
SB NINE SIXTY FOUR SO MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WOULD TESTIFY
IN FAVOR OF SB NINE SIXTY FOUR.
ONE ONE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT WE ARE NOT
HEARING ANYONE VIOLATING YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI I'M I WANT A
WEAPON AND I IN THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE BUT VERY
CONFUSING OKAY. HELLO YES YOUR-
BUILDING A MEDIA ONLY LET PEOPLE
. RIGHT OKAY ANY OTHER WOODEN
AND SOME OF A. NINE SIXTY FOUR.
ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HELLO MY NAME IS JONATHAN GO
I'M CALLING FROM THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
I'M CALLING AT THE PORT SB NINE
SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. BY
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS DANIEL HURWITZ I'M
THE ASSOCIATE CLINICAL DIRECTOR
FOR DEAL FAMILY AND YOUTH
SERVICES INTEREST AREA THREE AND
LOS ANGELES PASADENA SAN GABRIEL
I AM. SHORTER AND I RESPECT SAY
THOUGH YEAH THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. BY ONE THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO ROBBERY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH AGENCY OR THANK
YOU THANKS WITNESS. FIND ONE
SIXTEEN A LINE OF OPEN. YES
DONNA THANKS REPRESENTING
LUGGAGE WITH COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IF REPORTED SB NINE
SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. ONE FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT YES
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE ONE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON EMORY SHE'D WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR'S POSITION OF
CALIFORNIA WITH THE SUPPORT OF
AMENDED PETITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NFC LINE
ONE OR SIXTY FIVE SORRY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT FINANCIAL WE HAVE NO
OTHER ONLINE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
OKAY- SO MODERATORS NOW PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR PEOPLE
WHICH TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION SB
NINE SIXTY FOUR. BOTTERILL. OKAY
YEAH- YES YOU WISH TO COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ONE
ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ONE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY WHAT WOULD ONE ONE
THIRTY ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SANDRA
COMMENTS AND I'M JUST A REGULAR
OLD BUSINESSMEN AND CALIFORNIA
AND I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE. A
POSITION JUST MORE AND BURKE
OKAY HEAR ME SO THIS AGAIN- THIS
IS ON SB NINE SIXTY FOUR SO YOU
OPPOSE AND I SB NINE SIXTY FOUR
. WHAT ONE LIKE I SAID I'M NOT
SURE IF I AND SO MUCH IN
OPPOSITION BUT GETS QUESTION.
WELL THIS IS THIS IS THIS IS
EITHER YEARS EXPRESSING SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION THIS IS THE
OPPOSITION TIME SO. THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. OPPOSITE IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
NEXT NEXT WITNESS. THANKS TO ONE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME'S JANET ONE AND I
THINK I HAVE NOT DONE THIS
PROPERLY AND OPPOSING- SB
FOURTEEN ARE ACTIVELY NINE OKAY
WE ARE CURRENTLY ON SB NINE
SIXTY FOUR- SO- PLEASE- WAIT
UNTIL WE GET TO THAT ITEM ON
THEIR AGENDA THANK YOU. X.
WITNESSES THANK YOU. MEXICO LINE
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS NATALIE WEBER WITH HILL
ALLIANCE IN CALIFORNIA. STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB NINE SIX FOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU EXCELENTES. THANKS
TO THE POINT FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH HI THIS IS DONNA
PORTAL FROM HARD LANDING
RANCHING SACRAMENTO I OPPOSE-
THE- HELLO I LIKE THE HOLISTIC
APPROACH AND WEBER THANK YOU
LORD. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ONE
ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS LINE ONE FIFTY ONE. YES-
I WAS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
OPPOSE SB FOURTEEN NO THIS IS
ASPIN NINE SIXTY FOUR SO PLEASE
SO WE TOO WE GET THAT TIME AN
AGENDA SO AGAIN REMINDER- WE ARE
CURRENTLY ON SB NINE SIXTY FOUR
WE ARE TAKING. TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE SIXTY FOUR
WHICH SOME BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
USE EXPRESS INTRODUCED YOURSELF
TO NAME. A FEW REPRESENT
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. LINE ONE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY ONE
EIGHTEEN LINES OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I. FORTY NINE THIS IS
AGAIN WE'RE ON S. B. NINE SIXTY
FOUR. JERRY HAVE NOONE ELSE IN
Q. IT'S TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH OKAY LET'S BRING
YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON SB NINE
SIXTY FOUR. CENTER GROVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR RIGHT CENTER
WE ARE I DO APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
REPRESENT A RURAL AREA EVERY
TIME I GO OUT TO TWENTY NINE
PALMS OR- THE BAD CHINA LAKE
NAVAL AIR WARFARE CENTER WHERE
VETERANS ARE VALIANTLY SERVING
OUR COUNTRY- ONE OF THE BIG
ISSUES THEY HAVE. IS- IS THAT
THEY HAVE TO DRIVE THREE HOURS
AND FIVE HOURS DEPENDING ON
WHERE THEY'RE AT. TO LOS ANGELES
TO GET MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND IT'S FIRST COME FIRST SERVE.
AND SO- A LOT OF TIMES THEY
DON'T GET SERVICES. SO MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS ISSUES GOING ON
DRIVE FIVE HOURS SEE A DOCTOR
CAN'T SEE A DOCTOR IF YOU WAITED
ALL DAY. IT'S VERY DIFFICULT SO
I APPLIED YOUR BILL. I DO HAVE A
QUESTION THOUGH- AND I'M NOT
TRYING TO BE DISRESPECTFUL IN
ANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM BUT WHY
ARE WE DOING A STUDY WHERE WE
JUST IMPLEMENTING THIS PIECE OF%
LEGISLATION BECAUSE- WE ALL KNOW
WE HEAR IT FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT WE DESPERATELY. NEED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES PROVIDED
SPECIFICALLY AFTER COVE IT AND
EVERYTHING THAT HAS GONE ON THE
LAST TWO YEARS- AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR BILL AT THIS GREAT STEP
FORWARD BUT WHY ARE WE JUST
MAKING THIS. A PIECE LEGISLATION
THAT SAYS WE WILL DO THIS TO YOU
TO BE CLEAR YOU'RE THE ONE I
CHATTED BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT THE
SCOPE OF PRACTICE STUDY. THE
SEATTLE THIS IS A PRACTICE. OF
THE BILL ITSELF IS NOT A STUDY
IT DOES A LOT OF THINGS BUT- MY
UNDERSTANDING IF YOU'RE-
CONCERNED A CONCERN THAT I
SHARE. WITH MILITARY I'M SORRY
EXPANDED ON THAT I APOLOGIZE. SO
THERE IS FOR VETERANS ON THIS
COMMITTEE- FOR VETERANS EACH ONE
OF US HAD NMOS WE SERVED THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY- WE HAVE
THAT SKILL SET- THAT WE LEARN
FROM THE MILITARY WE SHOULD BILL
TRANSFER. TWO CALIPHS. I MEAN
THE OTHER STATES WHY CAN'T WE
JUST MAKE THE VETERANS IT HAD
THE SKILL SET OR CUT OR
INDIVIDUALS WHO COME FROM OTHER
STATES. NOT HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE ENTIRE CALIFORNIA
REQUIREMENT AGAIN SO WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL HELP YEAH SO- I DO SO
YOUR CONCERNS I UNDERSTAND THAT
WHICH IS A CONCERN I SHARE IS
THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE. WHO HAVE
BEEN TRAINED OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO IF SOCIAL WORK
OR- OR WHATEVER THE QUESTION
MIGHT BE. WHO ARE TOTALLY
QUALIFIED TO PERFORM SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA YES SIR BUT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO GET. A JOB RE.
TRAINING CERTIFIED AS IF YOU
WERE JUST LIKE COMING OUT OF
COLLEGE FRESH- WITH NO
EXPERIENCE. UNDER CALIFORNIA
LAW- AND I- SHARE THAT. CONCERN
AND THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE STOP.
I'M VERY FIRST OF ALL TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE LIKE
HERE ARE A TO PROP TO THE FULL.
EXTENT OF THEIR TRAINING AND ARE
NOT BEING LEGALLY RESTRICTED.
FROM PRACTICING IN AREAS THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN FULLY TRAINED TO
PRACTICE AND- AND THEN ALSO TO
LOOK AT- RETIRED. PEOPLE WHO ARE
FROM OUT OF STATE AND ARE THERE
SOME SITUATIONS WHERE WE CAN
HAVE SOMEONE TO SORT OF WAVE AND
WITH MUCH MORE LIMITED-
TRAINING- EXAMINATION BE ABLE
TO. BE CERTIFIED TO PRACTICE
HERE I SUPPORT THAT- AND- AND
THAT'S WHAT THE STUDY WITH THEM
I UNDERSTAND YOU WOULD PREFER
THAT SORT OF A STUDY WE JUST. DO
IT- AND THERE MIGHT RESPONSES TO
FOLD- THERE ARE SOME
COMPLEXITIES ARE ALWAYS GOING TO
BE SOME COMPLEXITIES ABOUT
DIFFERENT. KINDS OF SCOPE IN
MAKING SURE THAT SOMEONE
ACTUALLY DID RECEIVE THE
TRAINING. IN A PARTICULAR AREA
SO- I THINK STUYING IT MAKES
SENSE. BUT ALSO JUST TO BE A
BLIND AS CENTER ROTH KNOWS MORE
THAN MOST- SCOPE OF PRACTICE IS
ALWAYS. ONE OF THE MOST
CONTENTIOUS ISSUE THIS
LEGISLATURE. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
NURSE PRACTITIONER AND- NURSE
PRACTITIONER LEGISLATION IT TOOK
WHAT TEN YEARS YEARS TO GET
THAT. PASSES A HUGE PIPE TO
NURSE PRACTITIONERS AND
PHYSICIANS. AND YEAH IT.
HAPPENED. START DO I AND I STUDY
IT'S GONNA BE MY SMOOTHER THINK
RATHER THAN SOMEONE TO
INTRODUCING A BILL SO I WANTED
THIS SO I SHARE YOUR FRUSTRATION
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT HAPPENED
YESTERDAY IT IS OUTRAGEOUS THAT
PEOPLE AT THE DRIVE FOUR HOURS
AND FIVE HOURS- AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL ALSO DOES FOCUS THIS
WILL BRING RESOURCES I BELIEVE
IN TO RURAL AND LIKE COMMUNITIES
JUST TO LIVE. AREA OR I TO HAVE
EASIER ACCESS TO GUNS ALSO I
SURE YOUR CONCERN BUT THAT'S I
THINK THE NINE AMIK THAT WERE
DEALING WITH I APPRECIATE YOUR-
COMMENTS I APPRECIATE THE
RESPONSE IT IS. YES STUDY BACK
SO THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES IN UR
COMMUNITY I APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THE STEPS TO MOVE FORWARD
I REALLY DO WISH- WE COULD JUST
COME TOGETHER AND NO MATTER
WHO'S BEATING DOWN OUR DOOR STEP
WE CAN MAKE THE RIGHT DECISIONS
FOR CONSTITUENTS AND I KNOW
THAT'S DIFFICULT- DURING THIS
BUILDING BUT I APPRECIATE YOU
DOING. ONE THING JUST TO BE
CLEAR IN TERMS AWAITING IT- YOUR
TO THAT FOR THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE YEAH. FOR THE OTHER A-
BILL THOSE ARE GOING TO AFFECT.
YOU KNOW JANUARY THIRTY FIRST
ACTUALLY SOONER BECAUSE I THINK.
THIS IS ULTIMATELY CAN BE A LOT
OF BUDGET WORKING CENTER EGGMAN
IS DOING A LOT ABOUT WORK. AS
WELL AND REALLY LEADING ON THE
BUDGET SIDE. AND WE'RE GOING TO
BE SUBMITTING A SIGNIFICANT
BUDGET REQUEST. RELATED TO THIS
BILL AND THE GOVERNOR HAS PUT
MONEY IN THE BUDGET. SO THERE
WILL BE I THINK. I'M ASPECTS OF
THIS BILL THAT ARE LIKELY TO BE.
IN PLACE UPON A SIGNATURE IN THE
BUDGET. THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
AGAIN. OKAY THANK YOU. NEXTWE
HAVE CENTER RUBIO FOLLOWED BY
CENTER ROCKS AND THEN CENTER
EGGMAN OKAY. THE CHAIR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AS ALREADY MENTIONED
THERE IS A HIGH NEED FOR MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND YOU
KNOW DUE TO THE CIRCUMSTANCE IN
THE PAST TWO YEARS PIEPER EVEN A
PROFESSION THAT SOCK CLEAR NOT
ONLY IN THAT SPACE EDUCATION AND
OTHER AREAS BUT WE DEFINITELY-
ALREADY HAVE A LOT OF BARRIERS
SAD- THAT WE HAVE THE CONTENT
BUT THEN I THINK THAT. WE HAVE
TO DO BETTER TRAINING COURAGE
PEOPLE TO JOIN THE WORK FORCE OF
WE WANT TO DELIVER THE SERVICES
WE NEED HERE IN CALIFORNIA THEN
WE NEED TO DO BETTER TO
ENCOURAGE THAT OUR FIRST TO COME
FORWARD. WE SHIP FACT THAT DOC.
YOUR THERE'S TO THE COMPANY NINE
OTHER SCOPE OF PRACTICE IS
ALWAYS A CHALLENGE AND SO
GATHERING DATA AND MAKING SURE
THAT. THERE IS A STEADY I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT SO WHEN YOU DO
GET IT DONE IT'S DONE AND THE
RIGHT WAY SO NOT ONLY DO I WANT.
TO- AS A CO AUTHOR BUT I WANT TO
MOVE FORWARD WHEN APPROPRIATE
THANK YOU. OKAY THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY US AND RUBIO- SENATE
ROTH. THANK YOU MISTER CURE YOU
KNOW IN THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE- MY
PREDECESSOR CERTAINLY AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE I'VE BEEN ON
BOARD WE HAVE OF FOCUSED A LOT
ON PORTABILITY AND THE ABILITY
TO MOVE FROM STATE TO STATE IN
CALIFORNIA- I PRESUME IN THIS
AREA AS IN MANY AREAS. HAS SOME
HISTORICAL REQUIREMENTS SOME OF
WHICH CAN CONTINUE TO MAKE SENSE
SOME OF WHICH DO NOT. THAT WE
EXPLORE OF INCLUDING- THE
REQUIREMENT TO PERFECT YOUR
PRINT CHECKS AND MANY OF THESE
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONS AND
UNFORTUNATELY IN CALIFORNIA-
ELECTRONIC- LESSCANCER NOT OF.
ACCEPTABLE IF YOU'RE COMING IN
FROM OUT OF STATE YOU FREQUENTLY
HAVE TO DO A HARD CARD WITH ALL
THE PROBLEMS THAT. ARE
FINGERPRINT CARD CAUSES. I WAS
NOT PARTICULARLY AND
SPECIFICALLY AWARE OF SOME OF
THESE ISSUES BUT WE DO NOT HAVE
TO WAIT A YEAR OR TWO TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES WE HAVE A- SPENDING
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS DO WE
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO. TO DO
ONGOING SUNSET REVIEW AND CLEAN
UP SUNSET REVIEW AND- I LOOK
FORWARD TO OBVIOUSLY I SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH SENATOR WIENER. TO
TRY AND ADDRESS OF THE MORE
EMERGENT ISSUES- SOONER THAN.
THEN THE COMPLETION OF THE- THE
BADLY NEEDED STUDY SO JUST
WANTED TO SAY THAT WERE ON IT
THÀNH WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT THE
ISSUE THAT SENATOR LIMÓN REYES
TO. A WHILE AGO WHICH SEEMS- ON
USUAL TO ME SO THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- BAKER SIR SIR
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATE WINNER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I LOOK
FOR TO OUR ON GOING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS AS YOU
SAY VERY CRITICAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND I THINK WE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE. THE SEVERITY OF OUR
WORKFORCE CRISIS ESPECIALLY AS
IT RELATES TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH-
I HAD MY STUFF LOOK REAL QUIK
AT ABOUT THAT ISSUE DID THE BBS
IS VERY DIFFICULT TO WORK WITH
AND- I'VE ALSO. IN ADDITION
SENATOR TRY TO MY TIME BOTH THE
ON BMP. TO DO SOME OF THESE WORK
FORCE ISSUES AND- AND SCOPE
ISSUES ARE DIFFICULT AND
HOPEFULLY THIS HOPEFULLY THE
CRISIS IS SUCH THAT WE CAN ALL.
DECIDE TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY
TOGETHER TO TAKE CAR OF THIS.
AND I THINK I THINK BELIEVE THIS
IS DOUBLE REFERRED BECAUSE I.
ONE OF MY ISSUES IS ALSO MORE%
AROUND THE EDUCATIONAL COMPONENT
OF IT- ESPECIALLY FOR SOCIAL
WORK WE HAVE A- A NATIONAL. TO
EVERY EVERY SCHOOL WAIT WHEN MSW
IS MORE VALUABLE SOMEONE SAY.
THE OTHER DEGREES BECAUSE OF
YOUR DEGREE IN COUNSELING
SOMETHING ELSE NO ONE KNOWS WHAT
THAT IS. IF YOU GET AN MSW THAT
AROUND THE WORLD PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT THAT IS AND THERE'S
ESTABLISH CRITERIA NO MATTER
WHAT STATE YOU'RE IN IF YOU'RE
IN. YOUR EUROPE. OR FEAR IN.
MINNESOTA OR CALIFORNIA. THERE'S
A CERTAIN CRITERIA THAT MUST BE
MET BE A LICENSED. OR
ACCREDITED. PROGRAM SO THERE
SHOULDN'T BE ANY ISSUES WITH.
PORTABILITY ACROSS. THE STATE
SET THERE IS- BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS I THINK WE REALLY NEED TO
FOCUS ON. IS THIS ISSUE OF OUR
POLICIES PUSHING FOR MORE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IN OUR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS WHICH IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BUT I
BELIEVE WHAT HAS HAPPENED IS A
LOT OF OUR GRADUATE PROGRAMS
HAVE REDUCED BECAUSE THEY'RE
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE TO ADMIT.
AND OUR BACHELOR'S PROGRAM SOME
GROUND. WHICH ISN'T MUCH LESS
EXPENSIVE SO. IN MY IN MY SMALL
AMOUNT OF RESEARCH I'VE DONE ON
IT SCHOOL THAT USED TO ADMIT
COHORTS OF THREE HUNDRED MSW ARE
NOW ADMITTING COURTS ONE HUNDRED
. BASHERS PROGRAMS HAVE TRIPLED
IN SIZES AND SO THEN YOU HAVE
ALL THESE BACHELORS LEVEL PEOPLE
WHO DON'T HAVE A MASTER'S DEGREE
PROGRAM TO GO TO. AND THEY END
UP GOING SOMEWHERE ONLINE PAYING
A LOT OF MONEY GETTING INTO
OFTENTIMES AND NOT BEING ABLE TO
GET THEIR LICENSE. AND CREATING
A LOT MORE ISSUES SO IT REALLY I
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE C.
ISSUES IN THE UC'S. ON THE SLOTS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE AVAILABLE
FOR THE STUDENTS. THANK YOU IF I
COULD JUST SAY- YOU KNOW CENTER
A MAN SPECIFIC ON HIS BILL TO I
KNOW IT'S ALSO BUDGET ISSUE. IF
THERE ARE SPECIFIC THOUGHTS YOU
HAVE ABOUT HOW WE CAN STRENGTHEN
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS THAT
MORE M. S. W.'S- BUT IF THEY'RE
WAYS WE CAN STRENGTHEN THE IN
THE BILL WE REALLY WALK. YOUR
THE SPACE FOR ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ALWAYS NEED IN ORDER FOR
SOMEONE TO GET LICENSE THEY HAVE
TO HAVE POSTGRADUATE. SUPERVISED
HOURS. AND SO THAT IS ONE OF THE
ISSUES OF A LOT OF NONPROFITS
AREN'T ABLE TO HIRE SUPERVISE
THAT SOMEONE WITH A LICENSE. WHO
CAN SUPERVISED. PEOPLE ALL KINDS
OF NONPROFITS BUT WHAT WOMAN
SHELTERS EVERYWHERE SO. IT MIGHT
JUST BE ANOTHER COMPONENT WE
THINK ABOUT. LIKE A UNIT OF
SUPERVISORS REVIEW JUST. ONE
SUPER. CARE FOR FOLKS. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. C. NINE- SO SIR WIENER
PRESHEAF BRAIN IS BUILT ITS-
QUITE CALM FOR ACTUALLY TO OF
LOS PARTS APPRECIATE YOU WORKING
WITH HER TO ME TAKING
AMENDMENTS- AND ACTUALLY THERE'S
A CON ABOUT THIS IT IS GOING TO
BE HEARD AND ACTUALLY AND
EDUCATION COMMITTEE NEXT
TONIGHT'S THEMSELVES CERTAINLY
WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO TAKE A
BITE AT THAT AS WELL AND- I
GUESS I WILL ALSO HERE IT IS
WHAT I WILL ALSO BE THERE. AGAIN. WITH THAT- SO AGAIN THE REAL
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS IT
IS IMPORTANT WE FELT THAT
BEHAVIOR HEALTH PIPELINE. DO I
TO KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE.
MANY OTHER PROPOSED WHICH I
YOU'RE TRYING YOUR CALL. WITH
BUDGET FOR. SO PROPOSAL FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S AT CETERA THAT WE
NEED TO COORDINATE ALL THESE
PIECES TO. BUT WITH THAT-
CERTAINLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL WHICH IS LIKE THE CLOSEST.
I THINK THAT THIS. HERE IS
CALLER. SHOW THAT THIS IS LIKE
TO. OF MIND. NOT JUST HERE BUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THE
FACT THAT YOU KNOW. THAT THEIR
PEOPLE EVEN IN ARE REALLY
URBANIZED AREAS THAT MADE YOU
WANT TO SEE A THERAPIST. AND
STRUGGLE TO FIND A THERAPIST WHO
HAS AVAILABLE SLOTS EVEN IF THE
PERSON CAN PAY. A LOT AND DON'T
TAKE INSURANCE BECAUSE INSURANCE
DOESN'T REIMBURSE THE WAY SHOULD
JUST FINDING SOMEONE PURCHASE
BASIC NOT FOR CRISIS CARE JUST
FOR BASIC. HAVING SOME THE PRESS
. CITING TALK TO SOMEONE- IT IS
A REALLY- A HUGE AND I'M SO.
EVEN ON SIDE WE WERE. A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS OR EXPERIENCING I
AM HAPPY THAT SOCIETY AT LARGE
IN THE BODY POLITIC OR FINALLY
FOCUSING ON THIS AND RECOGNIZING
POST CODE OF IT BECAUSE IT'S
BEEN SO SEVERE. HOW IMPORTANT
THIS IS SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE DISCUSSION TODAY LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
NOT JUST ON THIS BILL BECAUSE
LIKE I'M GOING TO A FAMILY BILLS
AND BUDGET PROPOSALS AND SURVEY
GROUP OUT FOR AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO. GETTING SOMETHING DONE THIS
YEAR SO I REQUEST THAT I WROTE
OKAY THANK YOU SIR WIENER- THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED REFER TO THE KIA
EDUCATION IT'S BEEN SECONDED BY
CENTER RUBIO. LEAF BECAUSE OWN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PAN HI PAN
HI MELINDA'S MELINDA'S I EGGMAN
EIGHT ITEMS PLUS CONSULT WITH
AYE AYE GROVE. AYE HER TADO
LEYVA LEYVA. AYE LIMÓN. ROTH
ROTH IRA RUBY. I GREW AYE WIENER
ALL RIGHT WIENER HI. K. THAT
BILL GROSS HAS NINE FOR BILL
CALL. ALL RIGHT- SO A QUICK IN.
SO FIRST OF ALL GOING NEXT HERE
I NUMBER FIVE BY CENTER. AND YOU
COME UP. AT THE- OF. GIVEN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST IN A
SPECIFICALLY ITEM NUMBER TEN SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE UNLESS
THERE'S OBJECTION WE WILL HEAR
THAT AFTER WE FINISH HEARING
CENTER WE SAYS BILL SB NINE CASE
SO THAT'S BEEN REQUEST BY SOME
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS THEIR
INJECTION TO. CHANGING THE ORDER
OKAY SO JUST WANNA MAKE NOTE FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE WATCHING
THIS HEARING THAT WE WILL AFTER
WE COMPLETE ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
NINE EIGHT EIGHT WE WILL THEN
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER TEN SP
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE AND THEN
WE WILL. GO BACK TO THE POWER.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT- A WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- AS I PROMISED LAST YEAR
WHEN WE ARE THE LEGISLATURE-
PAST SB THREE ELEVEN THE
COMPASSIONATE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS CYCLE RICKSHAW FOR
RYAN'S LAW- HI PROMISED TO BRING
BACK A CLEANUP LANGUAGE BECAUSE
THERE WAS SOME CONCERN AND SOME
MAYBE SOME. UNCERTAINTY A PRESS
TO HOW THIS LAW LAW WOULD BE
APPLIED IN WHO WOULD APPLY TO.
IN SOME AREAS NOT GENERALLY BUT-
THIS IS THE CLEAN UP BILL. AND
SO FAR SO GOOD IN TERMS OF- THE
LANGUAGE THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO- AGREE TO WITH THE INDUSTRY
RUNS LAW REQUIRES HOSPITALS AND
CERTAIN TYPES OF POLICIES
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES TO STATE.
IN THE STATE TO ALLOW TERMINALLY
ILL PATIENTS ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS. THIS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. APPROVE RYAN SLOW
WITHIN ELEVEN TO ZERO VOTE LAST
YEAR. AND THE FULL SENATE AND ON
TO PASS A THIRTY SIX TO ONE.
AND- ACCORDING. TO THE INDUSTRY
SOME HEALTH FACILITIES AND
PHARMACISTS HAVE RAISED CONCERNS
THAT- THAT THIS BILL- MAY HAVE
SOME UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES IN
AREAS- THAT- MAY INCLUDE
ACQUIRING PHYSICIAN ORDERS-
THAT- IT WOULD REQUIRE
PHARMACISTS VERIFICATIONS FOR
SUCH ORDERS OF. OF IN- FACILITY
CANNABIS- PRODUCT AND- THAT THE
PHARMACY OVERSIGHT OF MANAGEMENT
ANDUSE OF WOULD ALSO BE
TRIGGERED- SO- WE WE'VE
CLARIFIED THAT IN THE BILL THAT-
OR BILL DOES NOT. MAKE
REFERENCES TO. THE ACTUAL
SCHEDULE OF DRUGS SO- ONE OF THE
MEN MENTION THIS BILL REQUIRES
HEALTH FACILITIES WITH REGARD TO
MEDICAL CANNABIS TO COMPLY WITH
THE DRUG AND MEDICATION
REQUIREMENTS APPLICABLE TO
SCHEDULE TWO THREE AND FOUR
DRUGS- THE- ACCORDING TO CDPH
THIS AMENDMENT WAS INTENDED TO
REQUIRE HEALTH FACILITIES TO
ENSURE PROPER STORAGE. AND
TRACKING OF MEDICATION. AT TWO
ALLOWS YOU TO BE H. TO MONITOR
THE STORAGE AND TRACKING. OF THE
ACTUAL OF. INGREDIENTS SO. OF
THIS OF THIS BILL SIMPLY AIMS TO
CLARIFY THEIR INTENT. I
APPRECIATE- THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL TO
MAKE SURE WE GET IT RIGHT. AND I
US FOR NOT A VOTE IN HELPING US
MOVE THIS BILL THROUGH PROCESS
AND SO FORTH. FOUR HOURS I'M I'M
INFORMED WE DON'T HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIR HUESO- THERE IS-
NO FORMAL- LEAD TO A SUPPORTER
TESTIMONY- SO WE WILL NOW FOCUS
WILL NOW TAKE A ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
EIGHT EIGHT- THAT ANYONE INTO
YOUR ROOM TWO HUNDRED PLEASE.
INTRODUCE YOURSELF. AND
RETENTION COMES ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA NORMAL ANYWHERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED XENON A
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE EIGHT EIGHT
BUT SIR WE SELL. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK ON SUPPORT OF SB NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
DO AT THIS TIME. WHAT IF YOU UP
I THANK YOU. AGAIN IT'S NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO WITH ONE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CONOR SWEENEY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH FACILITIES HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE EIGHT EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANKS FOR
THIS. SHERIFF NO NOTHING SHE WAS
THE TIME I THANK YOU THE ONE OUT
OF MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINETY EIGHT WE
DO NOT HAVE A FORMAL LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES TO TESTIFY.
SO WILL THEN MOVE HERE TO ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED AREN'T ANY
WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINETY. C. NINE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
TO WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE EIGHT
EIGHT. BUT CENTER HUESO. YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT
THIS TIME. SURE YOU HAVE ONE IN
Q. THANKS NINE ONE SIXTY FOUR
CRUCIAL AT. ONE SIXTY FORTY LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO. SO AT THE END
INTRODUCE YOURSELF PLEASE WHAT'S
YOUR NAME. MANY PEOPLE. ARE
USUALLY DURING THE NIGHT OKAY
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES WHO IS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE EIGHT
EIGHT. WE'VE KNOWN UP UNTIL THIS
TIME THE STRUCTURE OKAY THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHTS OF BRING BACK TO
MEDIA QESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE BILL OKAY
TO MOVE US ARE ROUGH. NO
COMMENTS OKAY EIGHTY NINE A
SURVEY SO I THINK THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR WORKING ON THIS ISSUE A
NATO THIS IMPORTANT CLARA
CLEANUP OR CORRECTION FROM THERE
YOUR PREVIOUS BILL TO ALLOW
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THAT
CERTAINLY WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL- WE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE YES
TO SIMPLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THAT APPRECIATE ALL YOUR HELP.
AFTER THIS AND- YOUR HELP LAST
YEAR HELPING CUSTOMERS SHOULD
BRING MUCH OKAY THANK YOU TO THE
MOTIONS DO PASSED THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS AND SECONDED BY
CENTER ROCKS. CONSULT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN
FINALLY. MELINDA'S I A- EGGMAN
AND SALAS GONZALEZ I AGREE.
GROVE I HER TADO. LEYVA LEVI LEE
MON. ROTH THANKS FOR A IRA. HI
RUBIO AYE WIENER WE AYE. AT NINE
OKAY THE BILL'S CURRENTLY NINE
AND WILL BE- KEEPING THE ROLE
OPEN FOR HALF AN HOUR THANK
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. OKAY SO
RIGHT UP ON HOLD HERE. THANK YOU.
OKAY SO- IT NEXT ON THE LIST
WE'RE GOING TO GO WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN BY DOCTOR PAN WHICH
IS SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE WE
ARE GOING A LITTLE BIT OUT OF
ORDER- A DOCTOR PAN THE FLOOR'S
YOURS WHEN YOU'RE READY. TO HAVE
A TERM A LENDER SENATORS- SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE IS ABOUT
KEEPING CHILDREN SAFE OUR
STUDENTS SAFE AND ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY FOR PARENTS WHO
WANT TO KNOW IF THEIR CHILDREN
MAY HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO SERIOUS
DISEASE WHILE THEY'RE IN SCHOOL.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE CONTROLS FOR
THEIR SYSTEM THEIR SYSTEM FOR
THE BILL AND ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS REGARDING- CLARIFYING
THE ROLE THE CALIFORNIA PART
PUBLIC HEALTH. SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE IS A BILL BY
STUDENTS FOR STUDENTS TO ENSURE
THEIR RIGHT TO QUALITY IN PERSON
EDUCATION. THE CIVIC PLEA SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE REQUIRE
SCHOOLS TO DEVELOP OPING
NINETEEN TESTING PLANS THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE. ENSURES THAT SCHOOLS
PRESCHOOLS AND ONSITE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND CHILD CARE
CENTERS HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
IMPLEMENT THEIR TESTING PLANS.
CVHS WORK THROUGH THAT THE
PANDEMIC TO ENSURE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE GOOD TESTING
GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT BUT THERE'S
CURRENTLY NO REQUIREMENT FOR A
PLAN. CASE SEARCHES IN A COVERT
THREATEN SCHOOLS WHEN THEY'RE
NOT PREPARED TO TEST RECOVER
NINETEEN AND PARENTS NEED TO
KNOW IF THERE IF CASES ARE
SPREADING AND THEIR CHILD
SCHOOLS. WELL BACK SEIZE OUR
GREATEST- SUPPORT AND STUFF
FIGHT AGAINST A COVER NINETEEN
WE NEED MORE SAFEGUARDS TO
PREVENT FUTURE SCHOOL CLOSURES
AND CASE SEARCHES. OVER NINETEEN
POSES A SERIOUS HEALTH RISK TO
STUDENTS FACULTY NINETEEN RANKS
IN THE TOP TEN LEADING CAUSES OF
DEATH. FOR CHILDREN FORTY FIVE
TO FOURTEEN END OF PEOPLE
FOURTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR YEAR
OLDS BETWEEN JANUARY MAY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. FACT THAT OVER ONE
THOUSAND CHILDREN. UNDER THE AGE
OF SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN UNDER
HAVE DIED OF CARBON NINETEEN.
AND PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE-
PRESS ME EIGHTEEN HUNDRED KIDS
HAVE DIED OF CANCER PER YEAR. WE
SHOULD NOT DISMISS THE EFFECTS
OF COVER NINETEEN FILTER AND-
UNVACCINATED SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
HAVE SHOWN TO BE PRIMARY DRIVERS
OF COVER NINETEEN TRANSMISSION
AND PLUS ANGELES COUNTY
UNVACCINATED TEENS AGES TWELVE
TO SEVENTEEN WERE MORE LIKELY TO
TEST POSITIVE FOR COVERED
NINETEEN. UNVACCINATED ADULTS
AND EIGHT TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
TEST POSITIVE THEN VACCINATED
TEENS AND NEARLY HALF OF THE ONE
THOUSAND CASES RELATED TO SCHOOL
SPORTS. AND TWENTY OUT OF TWENTY
ONE TOTALS THE LADY UP FOR LYNC
TIME VACCINATED HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS. FURTHER WE KNOW
TESTING HELPS PREVENT SCHOOL
HOOSIERS. FACT SPORADIC SCHOOL
CLOSURES HAVE TAKEN A
SIGNIFICANT TOLL ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH AND WILL BE STUDENTS
PARENTS AND TEACHERS OVER THE
PAST TWO YEARS. TO READ THE
CYCLE SCHOOL OPENINGS AND
CLOSURES WE MUST DEVELOP COUNTRY
TESTING PLANS TO ENSURE ALL
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE IN
PERSON LEARNING ENVIRONMENT. THE
CURRENT PATCHWORK OF TESTING
REGIMENS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS HAVE SHOWN THAT SCHOOLS
WITHOUT FREQUENT TESTING. SUFFER
OF WINDOWS COMPARED TO THOSE
WITH CONCRETE TESTING PLANS. TO
REMAIN OPEN AND SAFE. IN THE
STUDY OF OVER TWO HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA'S SCHOOLS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE FOUNDED ON SAKE
OF IN NINETEEN TESTING
CONTRIBUTES TO THE SAFETY.
LEARNING OFF IT TO SCHOOL SICK.
STAFF WHAT FOR THE ROCKEFELLER
FOUNDATION FOUND THAT WEEKLY
TESTING CAN REDUCE IN SCHOOL
INFECTIONS BY 50% FINALLY SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE INSURERS
THAT COVER NINETEEN TESTING
EQUITY ACROSS THE STATE
PROVIDING BETTER DATA FROM
THANKS FOR ALL BACKS PASSED IT.
WOULD THING ACTS ALSO ALLOWS
PARENTAL TRANSFER AGAIN PARENTS
HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW IF THEIR
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO
THE SERIOUS DISEASE MEDIA DIDN'T
. THE FOURTEENTH OF NINE IS
CRITICAL TO ENSURE OUR HAVE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO STAY OPEN
AND PREVENT FUTURE SURGICAL THE
NINETEENTH. BUT THAT ESPECIALLY
AFTER I VOTE AND I HAVE TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT KELLY
HIKES. WITH FELIX AND ARE NOT
VISIT DEAF- FROM THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE AND A MEMBER OF
THE BERKELEY UNIFIED SCHOOL
BOARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATE PAN- FIRST UP I BELIEVE
IT'S SIX DAY. YEAH PLEASE STEP
UP MAKE A- YOU HAVE- TWO MINUTES
. TURMAN PAN BASED ONE DOES AND
MEMBERS OF THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
NINETY SEVEN. MY NAME IS KELLY
HIKES AND I SERVICE THE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS LEAD FOR HE
LEFT. THIS IS A CALIFORNIA
BASED. POPULATION GENOMICS
COMPANY. THAT IS DONE OVER TEN
MILLION CO THE NINETEEN TESTS
AND OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
VIRAL SEQUENCES WORKING TO
RESPOND TO THIS PANDEMIC. AND
PREPARE FOR THE NEXT. WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FIRST IDENTIFY
THE ALPHA VARIANT WHEN IT
ARRIVED IN THE U. S. IDENTIFY
PROJECT. INTO THE DELL. AND
SUCCESSFULLY FORECAST
INTRODUCTORY ON THE FRONT.
SEQUENCING KOBE. SAMPLES LET US
TO IDENTIFY THE FIRST CASE OF
DELTA CRON. AND INFORMED OUR
RECENT REPORT SHOWCASING THE NOW
DOMINANT B. A. TWO VARIANT. THIS
WORK HAS BEEN CRITICAL IN
INFORMING PUBLIC HEALTH
DECISIONS. AS MUCH AS WE'D LIKE
IT. COMPANIES TEAM ISN'T GOING
TO JUST GO AWAY IT IS IT IS
THAT. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
LIVE WITH AS IT CONTINUES TO DO
WHAT. BUT FIRES WHICH IS MUTATE
. ADAM WORKING OF NEXT THE DATA
NOT TO DEVELOP NEXT AND BACK.
MEDIC AND INFORM HEALTH WE MUST
CONTINUE TO TEST AND SEQUENCE
CODE. ROUTINE TESTING SERVES AS
AN EARLY WARNING SYSTEM TO
IDENTIFY A SYMPTOMATIC
INFECTIONS AND STOP THE CHAIN OF
TRANSMISSION TO PREVENT
OUTBREAKS. IN FACT EVIDENCE FROM
A RECENT REPORT PUBLISHED BY THE
ROCKEFELLER FOUNDATION FOUND
THAT WEEKLY TESTING OF STUDENTS
TEACHERS AND STAFF CAN REDUCE IN
SCHOOL INFECTIONS BY 50% FINALLY
WE'VE BEEN DISHEARTENED BY THE
PARTISAN DIVIDE ON COVE IN
NINETEEN IN WASHINGTON. WE SERVE
ON THE NATIONAL TESTING ACTION
PROGRAM AND HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY
LOBBYING THE HILL FOR COVERED
SUPPLEMENTAL THAT COULD AMONG
OTHER THINGS PROVIDE CONTINUED
FUNDING FOR SCHOOL BASED TESTING
IN THE TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
YEAR. A VOTERS. AS SOON AS
TOMORROW BUT DETAILS ON THE
SPECIFIC DOLLAR AMOUNT FOR
SCHOOL TESTING IS STILL UNCLEAR.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT EXISTING
FUNDS HAVE BEEN APPROVED FOR USE
BEYOND JUNE OF THIS YEAR. BUT
REGARDLESS OF WHAT LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT PAYS FOR TESTING WE
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
WILL MAKE THE BEST USE OF THOSE
FUNDS. IF THERE IS A PLAN IN
PLACE WHICH IS WHAT BILL
INSURERS. THESE ARE BRIDGE THE
STOPS SENATE BILL FOURTEEN NINE
AND I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T CATCH- YOUR REP. TODAY.
DURATION SIX THAT RESPOND TO THE
PANDEMIC DURING NINETY PASSED IN
THE PHARMACY. OKAY SUIT HE LIKES
TO KOBE. PER OKAY THANK YOU SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY-
THE NEXT WITNESS IS- I DIDN'T
CATCH THE NAME BECAUSE IT'S NOT
ON MY LIST. YOU THIS IS AUTHOR
DID NOT PROVIDE ME THAT WAS.
RIGHT ENOUGH. OF THIS. THE ANNA
THERE YOU ARE ANNA ANNA
PRONOUNCE YOUR LAST NAME FOR ME
PLEASE YEAH IT'S VAASTU DEV AS
YOU LIKE IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY YOU YOU MAY BEGIN YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES AS WELL THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
HELP COMITTEE MY NAME IS ON A
POSITIVE AND I THINK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE. I POST. PUBLIC INSTITUTE A
COVER NINETY TESTING SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO
SCHOOL BOARD DIRECTOR FOR
BERKELEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
OUR PROGRAM WORKS IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO PROVIDE
SCHOOLS WITH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO SET UP COVERT
TESTING PROGRAMS I'M HERE TODAY
TO TELL YOU THAT THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
NAVIGATED THE PANDEMIC ARE THE
ONES THAT HAVE BUS OPENED
BETWEEN MITIGATION MEASURES ONE
OF OUR MODEL DISTRICTS EVANS
CITY SCHOOL DISTRICT WHAT. BE
OPEN IT TWENTY TWO ONE I HAD OF
MANY DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BY SETTING UP A COVERT
NINETEEN TESTING PROGRAM FOR
STUDENTS AND STAFF REPENS WOULD
SEARCH THE EAST PALO ALTO
COMMUNITY AND OVER NINETY TWO
PER OF ITS ARE THERE FOUGHT TO
USE IN FLORIDA RECEIVE IN RETURN. EVEN ONE OF BEST. RATE FIRST.
WITH A 80% THE CHILDREN PART TO.
IN THE RAPID IN TEST PROGRAM.
WAS ABLE STAY OPEN TO DELTA
OVERCOME IS. MY MANY DISTRICTS
CLOSED DUE TO SEE SHORTAGES.
BETWEEN JANUARY AND MID FEBRUARY
TWENTY TWENTY TO NEARLY 30% OF
THE STUDENTS IN RAVENSWOOD.
TESTED POSITIVE FOR COVER
NINETEEN. HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR
THE STATE'S FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
HAVE A TESTING BENDER SINCE SIX
STAFF TO THEIR DISTRICT FOR
HELP. THEY WOULD HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO TEST THEIR STUDENT
POPULATION AMBLE SEPTEMBER.
BECAUSE OKAY DONE THIS. WITHOUT
THE CD PH IN. THAT ALLOWED
NINETY TESTING TO HAPPEN LOW
INCOME DISTRICTS LIKE RAVENS
WOULD. WOULD BE ABLE TO STAY
OPEN DURING THE PANDEMIC. WITH
THE ONSET OF NEW VARIANTS AND
FEDERAL INACTION TO SUPPORT
COVER NINETEEN TESTING.
CALIFORNIA MUST CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE PROGRESS IN TESTING
INFRASTRUCTURE CAPACITY BUILDING
AND FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS. AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH PROFESSIONAL WHO
IS WORKING CLOSELY WITH
DISTRICTS HROUGHOUT OUR STATE I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE THANK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
YOU DID IT RIGHT TWO MINUTES-
BONUS POINTS FOR YOU. OKAY WE
WANT TO CAN COME. PEOPLE WHO
WISH TO SERVE. TO HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM IF YOU WISH TO COME
FORWARD AND SUPPORT THIS BILL
PLEASE STEP UP TO THE MICROPHONE
IN YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION YOUR
POSITION PLEASE. PRESS ARE
TRANSGENDERS ADAM KEIGWIN
WITHOUT COME ON BEHALF OF
PRIMARY HEALTH AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. YES ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OKAY THEN WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. OKAY ANYWAY HAVE.
NINE IN Q. START WITH NINE ONE
SIX I'M SORRY LINE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM IN OPPOSE THEM OUR
MAIN SUPPORTERS TO PULL THESE
RIGHT NOW. WE'RE DOING A SUPPORT
RIGHT NOW MA'AM. OKAY ALTHOUGH I
DID GET BACK INTO THE QUEUE FOR
THEM OPPOSING THE SAME NUMBER.
YOU YOU'RE GONNA WANT TO UP WHEN
IT'S TIME. I'M SORRY YOUR QUEUE
UP WHEN IT'S TIME. I THOUGHT
PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN FOR HOLDING
. WHEN IT'S TIME FOR OPPOSITION
YES YOU WOULD PRESS ONE ZERO
WHEN THE TIME PROPOSITIONS RIGHT
NOW WE'RE DOING SUPPORT OKAY.
OKAY I'M NOT GOING TO DO IT THEN
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. ONE
ONE ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY
BROOK ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER LINE I'M FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHARLES
RIGHT ON BEHALF OF SUMMER BIO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN SEVEN NINE THANK YOUR
NUMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
CALLER. ONE ONE EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT MOVE
ON THE LINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHEN EIGHTY FOUR YEAR
ONE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
OPPOSE ALL GET BACK IN HERE. ONE
ONE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DATA QUEBECOR MEADOW
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. ONE ONE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE OF THE
FINANCIAL. REPRESENTATIVE AGAIN
NOTHING STRONG OR- THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. ONE ONE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON LOCAL MODESTO PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THANK YOU NEXT CALL. NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU AT THE START OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR MODERATOR
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO-
OPPOSITION AND WE DO HAVE TO
PLEASE CALL. WHO ARE REGISTERED
IN OPPOSITION- DOCTORED DURING
SEVENTY I HOPE I PRONOUNCED THAT
CORRECTLY IS- THE DOCTOR HERE.
YES SIR PLEASE STEP UP TO THE
MICROPHONE. AND JUST AS A
SUPPORT HAD YOU HAD TWO MINUTES
AS WELL SIR AND YOU MAY BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RON
DIVERSITY AND PRACTICING BRIDGE
THE PHYSICIAN WHAT THE FOCUS IN
PEDIATRIC EMERGENCY MEDICINE. MY
DOCTORAL BACKGROUNDS IN
STATISTICAL COMPUTING
COMPUTATIONAL DECISION MODELS.
I'M SPEAKING AS A SCIENTIFIC
ADVISER TO CALIFORNIA PARENT
POWER. ALL IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE I KNOW COMPETNG INTERESTS
FINANCIAL OR OTHERWISE. THE MANY
INSTANCES WHERE THE BURDENS AND
COSTS OF TESTING OUTWEIGH THE
BENEFITS NO DOUBT DR PAN HIS IN
HIS LIFE AND HIS CAREER TOLD
MANY PATIENTS HYDRATING REST
WITHOUT A SPECIFIC VIRAL
DIAGNOSIS. THE PANDEMIC LIKE
MANY OTHERS BEFORE IT I PROJECT
THE CLAIM MANY LIVES DEVOTING
MASSIVE RESOURCES TO IDENTIFY
EVERY CALL THAT INFECTION HAS
DONE LITTLE TO ALTER ITS COURSE
HERE ABROAD. IS SCANDINAVIAN THE
UK THEY'VE ABANDONED TESTING A
SYMPTOMATIC CHILDREN AND ADULTS
DENMARK ONLY RECOMMENDS TESTING
IF YOU HAVE SYMPTOMS AND OVER
SIXTY FIVE AND AT PARTICULARLY
HIGH RISK. NORWAY SAYS NO MORE
TESTING ANYONE WITHOUT SYMPTOMS
SPECIFICALLY RECOMMENDING
INCESSANT ANY CHILDREN EVEN WITH
SYMPTOMS THE UK HAS STOPPED ALL
SCHOOL BASED TEST AS OF APRIL
FIRST WILL OFFER ONLY THREE
TESTING SMALL AT RISK ADULTS.
MASS TESTING CHILDREN NOT
BENEFITING A SYMPTOMATIC OF
MINIMALLY SYMPTOMATIC TILE ONE
INEVITABLY RESULT IN LEARNING
LOS ONE WILL NOT ALTER TREATMENT
AS INITIAL TREATMENT DOES NOT
DIFFER FROM COMMON SEASONAL
VIRUSES. ROUTINE TESTING OF
SCHOOL CHILDREN HAS NOT BEEN
SHOWN TO SPREAD DISTRUST OF SO
THE SPREAD OF IT NINETEEN AND
DESPITE WIDESPREAD TESTING
CALIFORNIA WE EXPERIENCE A SURGE
IN CASE MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
WINTER OF TWENTY TWENTY.
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS MISS MORE
DAYS OF SCHOOL JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TO THE STUDENTS IN
ARIZONA FLORIDA AND TEXAS SOURCE
NEW YORK TIMES MULTIPLE SPEECH
READ- ABANDONED SCHOOL TESTING
PROGRAMS FOR THIS REASON DURING
ALMOST ON. A NO DOUBT MATHIS
TESTING WILL LEAD. TO HIGHER.
CHILDREN THANK OPEN SCHOOL DAY.
FOR PRISON CULVERT NINETEEN WHEN
THEY DO NOT HAVE IT. IN A RECENT
STUDY A HUNDRED NAY THOUSAND
PARTY. IN NEW ONLY THIRTY PER.
OF SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
PEOPLE WHO TESTED POSITIVE WERE
CONFIRMED TO BE INFECTED. HOW
MIGHT THAT PLAY OUT IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS. USING THE
SAME RATES OF POSITIVITY AS WELL
AS SENSITIVE. AS FIFTY ON THIS
TEST IN CALIFORNIA THE COMMUNITY
POSITIVITY RATE HAS TO BE MORE
THAN 6% RITUPARNA TEST TO SEE
PASSED. TEST SINCE MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE EXCEEDED THAT
POSITIVITY RATE FOR ONLY SEVEN
WEEKS DURING THE PEAK OF THE
OMICRON SEARCH FROM DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO DECEMBER
TWENTY SECOND TO FEBRUARY TENTH
. EXECUTORS YOUR AT YOUR TIME
LIMIT SORRY I APOLOGIZE- I'LL BE
OPEN TO QUESTIONS MORE DESCENT
RATE MAYBE YOU SHOULD TAKE A
SEAT THERE OF CASE- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE A QUESTION. PERHAPS
THEY'RE IN THE RIGHT YES THE
MARK YES NO THAT'S FINE YOU CAN
SIT WHEREVER YOU LIKE. OKAY THE
NEXT WITNESS IN OPPOSITION IS
HEIDI HALL WITH THE ROSE BILL
UNION HIGH SCHOOL YOU WORRY
DISTRICT TRUSTEE. A. B. AND WHEN
IT YOU'RE READY YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES AS WELL. THANK YOU HELLO
AND GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE I'M
HEIDI HALL AS SHE SAID FROM
ROSEVILLE JOINT UNION HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT RIGHT NEXT DOOR
IN PLASTER COUNTY. I WANT TO
EXPRESS TO YOU THAT EDUCATORS
AND PUBLIC SCHOOLS RIGHT NOW ARE
UTTERLY EXHAUSTED. THE OVER
REACHING COVERAGE PROTOCOL HAS
BEEN TAXING AND OVERWHELMING WE
HAVE BLATANT TEACHER
DISCRIMINATION ISSUES OVER THE
UNFAIR AND UNJUST TESTING OF
ONLY BE UNVACCINATED TEACHERS
AND IT'S THOSE SAME UNVACCINATED
TEACHERS WHO ARE CALLED UPON
TIME AND TIME AGAIN. SUPPAN
FILIN FOR THOSE WHO ARE BACK.
PORSCHE DAFT BECAUSE OF THAT
ISSUE MORE TEACHER RESIGNATIONS
EVERY MONTH DUE TO THE MANDATES
I WISH I HAD MORE TIME TO READ
TO YOU THE SLEW OF EMAILS THAT
WE GET FROM TEACHERS. THAT IT
DOES NOT A TO SUPPORT MANDATED
ON SITE SCHOOL TESTING CLINICS
THE HARM OF OVER TESTING HEALTHY
A SYMPTOMATIC STUDENTS HAS BEEN
PROVEN TIME AND TIME AGAIN
HEALTHY STUDENTS AND STAFF. HAVE
MISSED WEEKS AND WEEKS OF SCHOOL
AND SPORTS DUTIFUL POSITIVE
PROTESTS THAT HAVE NEVER SHOULD
HAVE NEVER BEEN ADMINISTERED IN
THE FIRST PLACE. TO QUOTE
SENATOR LEYVA FROM JUST THIS
MORNING SCHOOLS ARE STRETCHED
THIN WITH MANDATES FROM-
EMPLOYEES ARE STRESSED AND
EXHAUSTED AND AS A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER I COULDN'T AGREE MORE I
SEE IT IN MY DISTRICT WE OPENED
OUR DOORS IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY. BEFORE TESTING CLINICS
IN VACCINES WERE EVEN A THING
AND WE'VE STAYED OPEN EVER SINCE
WITH THAT BY FOLLOWING. EVERY
SINGLE FAMILY HAS ACCESS TO FREE
AT HOME TEST KITS THEY CAN GET
THEM IN THE MAIL THEY CAN GET
THEM AT OUR SCHOOLS PARENTS AND
FAMILIES THEN CAN CHOOSE WHEN
AND WHERE AND HOW TO TEST.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE NOT PUBLIC
HEALTH CLINICS NOR SHOULD THEY
BE IN THE SAME WAY WE DON'T TASK
. POSSIBLE WITH. CHILDREN
FRIEDMAN EIGHT WITH NOT CALLS
WITH THE ROLE OF MAINTAINING
MEDICAL TESTING FACILITIES. THIS
IS NOT WHAT EDUCATORS SIGNED UP
TO BECOME TEACHERS. I URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO ON THIS OVER REACHING
UNNECESSARY AND OVERLY X. THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL.
OF YOUR- QUESTION. YOU BROUGHT A
FAN CLUB ICY OKAY- SO WE WILL
MOVE ON TO ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION HE COULD PLEASE QUEUE
UP- MICHAEL. THANK AT THIS POINT
IN THE TESTIMONY WE ASK THAT YOU
JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND WHO
YOU'RE REPRESENTING IN YOUR
POSITION THANK YOU GO AHEAD. MR
THE CELLULAR AND COFOUNDER
FREEDOM ANGELS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. TARA THORNTON CO
FOUNDER FREEDOM ANGELS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THE
CASHIER WILLIAM SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
LIBRARIAN I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU ON THE BOOKS MOST MORE
MONEY FROM BOOK. THANK YOU.
WHERE THEY'RE FROM HI JEAN
FORMER LAFAYETTE SCHOOL DISTRICT
GOVERNING BOARD AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS VERONICA I RESIDE IN YUBA
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU. HI THIS
IS RICHA LATCH. FROM PLASTER
COUNTY AND I'M WORKING WHICH IS
PRETTY BROADLY FOR U. S. SENATE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS CHRIS
HEISSER I'M A CITIZEN AND A
TEACHER IN SOLANO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MA'AM. GOOD MORNING SHANNON
LETS US CITIZENS STOCKTON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. J. SET A REPRESENT YOUTH
SPORTS IN ORANGE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU COMPORTMENT HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTY MAURA I RESIDE IN
PLEDGING HOW CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MA'AM. MY NAME IS LUIS
ORTEGA I'M FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SIR. ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION GOING WHAT WE HAVE
MORE OKAY. RIGHT UP IN THE FRONT
SIR.
SIR ROBERT DISABLED AMERICAN
VETERAN I STRONGLY OPPOSE DOCTOR
PARENT. THANK YOU SIR SOMEONE AT
MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON I KNOW I
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME SO I
WANTED TO CREATE AN IN THE KNOW
YEAH I DON'T KNOW MA'AM I'M
SORRY WE'RE AT THE POINT OF
TESTIMONY WHERE YOU GIVE YOUR
NAME WHO YOU'RE REPRESENTING AND
SESSION ON THE BILL OKAY MY NAME
IS OUR HALL I AM BAKERSFIELD. I
OPPOSE BAIL AND I JESUS ALL OVER
YOU THAT THE GLORY OF GOD WILL
FILL THIS ROOM AND THAT GOD WILL
TOUCH YOU TODAY TO THE DECISION
A MAN THANK YOU MA'AM. MY NAME
IS CHARLES BILLS THEN YOU WON'T
DO THIS TO MY GRANDKIDS. ALL OF
YOU THERE AFTER THIS BILL YOU'RE
FIRED WE WILL TAKE YOU OUT OF
OFFICE. THANK YOU SIR GO AHEAD
MA'AM MY NAME IS JESSICA WAGNER
FROM STOCKTON CALIFORNIA I'M A
TEACHER AND I WAS REMOVED FROM
MY POSITION BECAUSE OF THIS
DISCRIMINATORY BILL. AND I
OPPOSE THIS. THANK YOU MA'AM. MY
NAME IS GABRIELLE FOUNDER OF
STAND UP SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
SHARON MCEWAN HARPER. I'M A CO
ORGANIZER. OF THE UNIFIED
AMERICANS CONVOY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL IT
APPEARS TO US THAT THIS IS ABOUT
FUNDING RATHER THAN THE SAFETY
OF OUR CHILDREN WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK AYE KIM. THANK YOU
COME ON UP. MY NAME IS AMANDA
PERTAIN I'M A CO ORGANIZER OF
CALIFORNIA STATE CONVOY AND
APPARENT FROM BUTTE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MA'AM. I'M SONY VEGAS AND I
AM A CONCERNED PARENT IN
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SONYA. COME ON
UP. YOU GUYS CAN LINE UP IN THE
FRIEND IF YOU'D LIKE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO STAY ON THE WAY BACK
THERE. MY NAME IS JAMIE CHOI
FROM YELLOW COUNTY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
DELFINO HERNANDEZ FROM KERN
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MA'AM. MY
NAME IS SARAH SHUGART FROM
RANCHO CORDOVA AND ICE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MA'AM SIR. JIM EDMONDS THE
BUSINESS OWNER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS BOB FROM WEST
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU BOB. MATT- AT
HELLO CHRISTINE FIORENTINI MY
DAUGHTER ISABELLA I'M A MAMA
BEAR AND A HOME SCHOOL MOTHER
NOW AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU MA'AM. MY NAME IS
JAMIE VALOR AND A CITIZEN OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
CINDY MCCURRY I'M A CONCERNED
PARENT A CITIZEN OF SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND I ENCOURAGE YOU
ALL TO DO THE RIGHT THING IN
OPPOSE IT AS WELL. THANK YOU
MA'AM. HELLO I. MARICELA FLORES
WITH I'M FROM SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
COURT LIBERTY COALITION I ALSO
REPRESENT- CATHOLIC FAMILIES FOR
FREEDOM. PLEASE HELP US PROTECT
OUR GOD GIVEN RIGHTS AS PARENTS.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM. MY NAME IS
ELLEN AND- MAY MAY WE BOTH DROVE
ALL THE WAY FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I AM A PARENT AND WE-
WORKERS I AM A SOCIAL WORKER
WITH A SOCIAL WORKERS. AND WE
HAVE FROM SAN FRANCISCO REVIVAL
SAN FRANCISCO WE ARE HERE TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL. ACCORDING TO
CDC AMANDA STEELE MANAFORT MA'AM
I'M SO SORRY BUT WE'RE AT THE
POINT OF TESTIMONY NOW WHERE
IT'S JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL HI. MY NAME IS
ELLEN. DROUGHT AND DISEASE MAY
MAKE FROM SAN FRANCISCO WE HAD
TO OPPOSE THE BILL HAS NO
BENEFIT FOR. THE NO BENEFIT
STUDENTS THANK YOU SO MUCH MA'AM. HI MY NAME IS JAMIE ANDERSON
I'M FROM BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
WHAT ABOUT ANTIGEN TESTING. FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD COVERT THANK
YOU MAY I NEEDS TO BE FACTORED
IN YOUR- I JUST WANT TO. REMIND
THE FOLKS WHO WERE WAITING TO
TESTIFY AND THERE MAY BE SOME
OUT THERE AND- MORE IN THE HALL
AS WELL I KNOW IT'S A LITTLE
FRUSTRATING THAT YOU CAN'T. YOU
KNOW. WE GIVE- PERHAPS A SPEECH
LIKE THE PREVIOUS- PEOPLE DID
WHO TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION BUT THAT'S HOW THESE%
COMMITTEES ARE RIGHT OTHERWISE
WE MIGHT BE HERE FOR WEEKS- SO
AT THIS POINT IN THE TESTIMONY.
IT IS YOUR NAME THE ORGANIZATION
THAT YOU'RE OR WHOEVER IT IS
YOU'RE REPRESENTING AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH GO AHEAD MA'AM HI MY
NAME IS TO BE WELDED I REPRESENT
MY GRANDCHILDREN AND MY GREAT
GRAND CHILDREN. WELL I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK. HI MY NAME IS
JOSH NAY EGGMAN AND I REPRESENT
ALL THE PEOPLE THAT ARE AGAINST
ALL THE SECRET SOCIETIES THAT
YOU GUYS ARE INVOLVED IN AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU SIR. REYES CHRISTOPHER AGNEW KERN
COUNTY CALIFORNIA. HERE'S IN
SUPPORT OF MY CHILDREN MY
GRANDCHILDREN I OPPOSE THIS BILL
ANYBODY SUPPORTS INSPIRED. THANK
YOU SIR GO AHEAD MA'AM. I'M A NO
WELL BUTTON FROM KERN COUNTY AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
KNOW. MY NAME IS CHERYL DOWNEY
I'M A CONCERNED PARENT AND
GRANDPARENT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL I'M FROM BUTTE
COUNTY. THANK YOU MA'AM. MY NAME
IS DAVID HOW LABELS. BROWN
PLASTER COUNTY IN AUBURN
REPRESENTING FOR MY DAUGHTER AND
I OPPOSE THIS. THANK YOU SIR. MY
NAME'S AARON KINGSTON FROM
CALAVERAS COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. COMING UP
MA'AM. HI EVERYONE MY NAME IS
STELLA PRESS SOME RETIRED LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM BAKERSFIELD AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL I
HAVE A TWELVE YEAR OLD. NOW
THANK YOU MA'AM. COMING UP SIR.
MY NAME IS JONATHAN IS ACTRESS
AND FOUNDER OF REOPEN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS REPRESENTING TWENTY
THOUSAND PARENTS WITH SCHOOL
CHILDREN ACOSTA ACROSS THE STATE
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. IS THAT IT OKAY. ALL
RIGHT I THINK THAT'S EVERYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
IN PERSON SO NOW- WE WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES. MISTER
MODERATOR ARE YOU THERE. YES
OKAY YOU WISH TO SPEAK. YEAH
MISTER MODERATE IF YOU COULD
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES IN JUST
IF YOU COULD GIVE ME AN IDEA OF
HOW MANY COLORS WE HAVE IN THE
QUEUE WAITING TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION I'D BE GREAT- SEEING.
ABOUT FORTY SO FAR OKAY IT'S
GOING. WOULD YOU- GO AHEAD AND
START WITH THE FIRST CALLER
PLEASE. YES IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN A POSITION OF SB FOURTEEN
SEVEN NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
IF YOU'RE NOT IN OPPOSITION IN
YOUR IN THE QUEUE PRESS ONE AND
YOUR AGAIN TO REMOVE YOURSELF
FROM QUEUE. WE'LL START LINE ONE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME'S KATHERINE AT PRIDE
FRAUDULENT CARCINOGENIC PCR
TESTING IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE. AN
ACTUAL ADELINE ONE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH HI MY NAME
IS NICOLE YAMA AND THE PAIR IN
PLASTER COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. ANYTHING CAN
BRING TO THE TABLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I JUST WANT TO
REMIND THOSE WHO ARE IN THE
QUEUE CALLING IN- IT'S JUST LIKE
THE PREVIOUS- WITNESSES IT IS
YOUR NAME WHO YOU'RE
REPRESENTING AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH I
HAD MISSED MODERATE IN NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MEXICO ONE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY HI MY NAME
IS MARY HOAGLAND I AM A MOTHER%
OF TWO I'M A CITIZEN IN THE
SEMINOLE COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB ONE FOUR SEVEN NINE
THANK YOU. YES GOING FIFTY FIVE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FIVE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONLINE MY
NAME IS TRISH I'M FIFTY NO NO NO
I'M HERE. HELLO MY NAME IS TRISH
MINHA I'M A RESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA CONCERNED PARENT.
CANNOT REPRESENT THE C. J. U. S.
T. PARENTS UNITED AND WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THE ONE ONE
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
YES MY NAME IS LAURIE BINHAI
REPRESENT PLATFORM PRIVATE
SCHOOL HOME SCHOOL STARTED FOR
REASONS LIKE THIS I ALSO
STANFORD SOS AVE OUR NUMBER DOT
COM WERE IN DISTRICT FIVE IN
BILL DODD DISTRICT WE HAVE NOT
BEEN HEARD AND WE ARE A FULL
OPPOSITION OF ANYTHING LIKE THAT
THE DEMANDS ANY TYPE OF COERCION
ON OUR CHILDREN. ONE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NICOLE
KRAUSS AND DENTURE COUNTY
SENATOR LIMÓN DISTRICT IN HARDLY
OPPOSITION FOR THE BILL. THE
NEXT MOVE ONE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS A GREAT
GUY LIVING SHASTA COUNTY I
REPRESENT MY CHILDREN AND ALL
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
TIRED OF THE MEDICAL TYRANNY I
AM STRONG OPPOSITION TO S. B.
ONE FOUR SEVEN NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. MEXICO NINE NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MERRY
NUMBER OLD LOW A CONCERNED
PARENT FROM ON THAT CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
BACK WITH THE GOVERNMENT
OVERREACH THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HI CHRISTY CONNORS I'M WITH BAY
AREA FREEDOM LLIANCE THREE
BILLION FOR PARENTS AND CHILDREN
TO HELP DEFENSE CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATE IF I COULD CUT IN FOR A
SECOND HERE JUST TO LET
EVERYBODY KNOW AT THIS POINT WE
pHAVE ONE HUNDRED AND SEVEN
PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE CALLING IN
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SO
THAT IS GOING TO TAKE. THAT IS
OKAY WE HAVE. A VERY HAPPY ABOUT
THAT- I JUST WANNA LET YOU KNOW
THAT THAT IT IS GOING TO TAKE
SOME TIME TO GO THROUGH ALL
THESE TESTIMONIES IF I COULD
JUST REMIND YOU. YOUR NAME- YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL- AND THAT IS ALL
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
RODERICK AHEAD NEXT CALLER. ONE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS DEBORAH LEAST MARTIN
CRAWFORD AND I LIVE IN VENTURA
COUNTY I AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL SB ONE FOUR SEVEN
NINE AS A GRANDPARENT AND AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR HER PROTECTING THE
EQUAL RIGHTS OF KIDS AS WELL AS
THE C. H. CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
. MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
ONE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI MY NAME IS TERRY BLAZER-
PLAIN DISTRICT LIVE IN DISTRICT
FIVE RESPOND REPRESENTING THE
WORST NUMBER NINE AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE ONE OF SIX WE HAD.
HI THIS IS DIANE MARIE FRYE AND
I'M IN A CINEMA COUNTY DISTRICT
TWO BUT AS THE WEST AND I'M IN A
STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS
TRAUMATIZING BILL FOR OUR
CHILDREN OF MY GRANDPARENTS AND
ALSO ITS LINK WITH THE GENOMIC
TESTING WITH CHINA THANKS VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY NINETY SIX RUNS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY WE'LL
MOVE ON THE LINE SIXTY SIX ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU I AM
MY NAME IS LINDA QUINLAN MEADOWS
I NEED TO KNOW PETERS- I'M IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND I
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SENATE BILL. THANK YOU EXCELLENT
NINE. THAT'S GOING TO- TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS DEBORAH
RADIO CALIFORNIA FREEDOM TO
CREEK AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JENNIFER GAS
THE CONCERNED PARENTS FROM SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY AYE OPPOSED TO
FILL IN ANY OF THESE VACCINE
MANDATE THANK YOU MA'AM NINE ONE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BUYING TO
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHRISTY DOWN OPEN STYLE
I IN THE CHAPTER CHAIR OF
MONSTER LIBERTY YOLO COUNTY AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS MARINA NETTLES AND ON
BEHALF OF CALLIE PARENTS UNITE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT COLOR.
BECHUANALAND ONE TEN ONE ONE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE
CALL- MY NAME IS DANTE MARQUEZ
I'M A MEMBER OF THE PATRICK
COUNTY FREEDOM COALITION I'M A
CONCERNED PARENT OF TWO AND I
ECHO BOTH THE OPPOSITION
SPEAKERS- AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS UNNECESSARY FILLED FOR
THANK YOU MA'AM THE- NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE THIRTY TWO. TWENTY
THIRTY TWO UNITED. THANK YOU OUR
ACCOUNT PLEASE AND I'M A MEMBER
OF WHICH THE CHOICE ADVOCACY AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER.
NEXT IN LINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES MA'AM. MY NAME'S.
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT COLOR. MEXICO LINE FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS NATALIE MEDIFAST I'M NOT A
TESTING OR JEAN THINK WITH THE
COMPANY I AM A REPRESENTATIVE
MARIN COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB. FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE ONE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IT WILL MOVE ON THE LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BRAD ANDERSON CONCERNED
CITIZENS CITY RESTAURANTS I'M
OPPOSED TO SENATE BILL ONE FOUR
SEVEN NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
YES WE SURE CAN'T HELLO YES GO
AHEAD THANK YOU MY NAME IS CARL
THANK YOU MY NAME IS KELLY ALIBI
I IN THE SITTING PRESIDENT OF
THE EL DORADO HILLS YEP R. W.
CHAPTER OF REPUBLICAN WOMEN I AM
ALSO THE ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES
OF DISTRICT ONE FOR THE
REPUBLICAN CENTRAL COMMITTEE AND
THOSE I REPRESENT OPPOSE THIS
BILL ALONG WITH MYSELF THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL MY NAME SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS ANNE. I'M A GRANDMOTHER AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS THANK
YOU. OKAY MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO AND- BINARY
TRIGGER HAD. THANK YOU- MY NAME
IS JANET PLUM ANOTHER SEVEN
GRANDMOTHER AT THIRTEEN- WE ARE
VERY CONFIDENT WITH OUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SEVEN ZERO ONE IS OPEN.
WELL CAN YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS MANDY
LUNA AND AS AN EDUCATOR IN A
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR AND THE
MOTHER OF FIVE I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WITH ME GO
AHEAD MA'AM YES. THIS IS DONNA
EDWARDS ALL PLASTER COUNTY
CONCERNED CITIZEN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE.
MISTER MODERATOR. ONE SIXTY
FORTY ONE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SUSAN
MARTIN- I MEAN PLASTER COUNTY
AND I COULD STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
ONE FOUR SEVEN NINE THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
TWENTY FIVE YOU WANT IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS A CRUCIAL. I'M
FOR MARIN COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LEAH MAY
CONSIDER IN ANY REGISTERED NURSE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB ONE FOUR SEVEN NINE
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS JOE
BENNING- FROM SIMPLE COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. ONE ONE NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD
. PUBLISHED IN THE CHOIR PARENT
HAS TO SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN IN
GLOUCESTER COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT COLOR. ONE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MARLYS
TRANSPARENCY Q. AND PLASTER
COUNTY AND THEY STRONGLY OPPOSE
S. B. ONE FOUR SEVEN NINE THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT COLOR. TWENTY ONE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO ALEXANDER GABBARD FROM SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
CATHOLIC FAMILIES FOR FREEDOM
CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE SELF THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER. ONE ONE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES GO
AHEAD WE CAN HEAR YOU. I DIDN'T
THIRTY TIMES IN MY COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB ONE. ONE
FOUR SEVEN NINE THANK YOU SIR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YES WE HAVE
ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHEN A LARGER NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA UNITED AND WE OPPOSE.
WELL THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
. ONE EIGHTY FOUR AT. HELLO I
NEED FOR YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY AN ESTIMATED
PHILIP FROM PARKER COUNTY AND
I'M A CONCERNED PARENT AND AN
ORGANIZER OF NINE NOR CAL
FREEDOM ALLIANCE RECOGNIZE THAT
THE PARENTS ACROSS NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS BRIAN GINTER I'M A RESIDENT
OF PLASTER COUNTY I'M A PARENT
AN ATTORNEY AND A MEMBER OF THE
PLASTER COUNTY FREEDOM COALITION
THE REASONS I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND DR PAN STERN AND
BOOK THE REAL. NUMBER TEN AND
ASK. I THINK WE GOT AN OPPOSER
OKAY. YEAH I UNDERSTAND I
UNDERSTAND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HIM PLAYED A MISTER MODERATOR
COULD WE HAVE THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE ONE ZERO EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
DENIS I'M A RESIDENT OF
CONVERTED COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE BETTER LEYVA I HOPE
YOU WILL OPPOSE IT SO OFTEN.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE ONE NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME IS JONI
I LIVE DANCE COUNTY AND ON MY
AND THE REST. ON BEHALF OF MY
THREE CHILDREN STOP. ARE HEALTHY
EIGHT MA'AM WE DO NEED- YOUR
NAME WHO YOU ARE. AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BODY ONE ROOM
EVERYBODY OF THAT- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CALL THAT MISTER MINER.
EIGHT ONE OKAY THANK YOU MA'AM.
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
FIFTY ONE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME
IS BILL I AM I'M A THE BURNT OF
THE CHILDREN IN. THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I UP THIS THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER.
WE HAVE ONE HUNDRED. WE'VE AHEAD
. KELLY BROWN AND I AM- THE ONLY
A WITH PERK AND I JUST OPPOSE
THE BILL FOURTEEN NINE. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ACTUALLY NINE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
MODERATOR BLIND. ONE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINES OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN ONE ONE ONE EIGHT.
TWENTY THREE WAYS. ONE EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IT WOULD GO ONLINE ONE
EIGHTY SIX ONE EIGHTY SIX GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME WE
CAN GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI MY NAME
IS CARMEN US AROUND I'M
CONCERNED MOTHER OF TWO FROM
TRACY CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE S. B. ONE FOUR SEVEN
NINE. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE SIXTY ONE
GO AHEAD. SENATOR MCGILL BEING
IN BALLOTING COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT COLOR. ONE ONE
SIXTY EIGHT GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS SUE BLACK IN A CONCERNED
PARENT IN CINEMA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THAT'S COOL. FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KENNETH FELD. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE TWO
ZERO ONE WE THOUGHT IT. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES MA'AM WE CAN
GO AHEAD HELLO YES GO AHEAD HI
MY NAME IS SERENA MY NAME IS
SERENA FLORES I'M FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY A MOTHER OF FOUR
CONCERNED PARENTS AND I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING CATHOLIC FAMILY FOR
FREEDOMS THANK TIMELY OPPOSED TO
FELT. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE THIRTY THREE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS CASSANDRA GONNA FROM KENNESAW
COUNTY AND I AM CODES ITSELF
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER.
NINE TWO ZERO SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE NAME OF THE DAIRY
ENGLERT I'M AN ATTORNEY. FOR
COOL LET THEM BREED AND I'M
CALLING REPRESENTS- AND MY OWN
FAMILY AS WELL AS THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE THANK
YOU. ONE TO FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS OPRY
BARBARA FROM ASCALON CALIFORNIA
AND REPRESENTING MY FOUR
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB ONE FOUR SEVEN NINE. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER. ONE ONE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS HENDERSON I'M A MOM
OF A SOPHOMORE IN CARMEL HIGH
SCHOOL I'M A LICENSED CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY AND I'M ALSO THE
FOUNDER OF CALIFORNIA UNITED WE
REPRESENT SOUTH AMERICA ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT COLOR
. NINE TO SIXTEEN TO ONE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ALEX LAMBRAKIS AND I AM
REPRESENTING MY CHILD AND
THOUSANDS OF OTHER CHILDREN IN
LOS ANGELES AND OPPOSING THIS
BILL. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE TWO HUNDRED
AND ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
TO ALLOW MY NAME AT. HELLO MY
NAME IS DENISE SANDERS AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY FAMILY
MY CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FINE ONE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS KIRTI THE PUBLIC WORKS
DIFFERENT EDUCATE ADVOCATE
MISTER FAMILIES WITH EXCEPTIONAL
NEEDS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE NINETEEN S. I NEWMAN
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHO
WILL MOVE ON THE LINE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THANK YOU
ONE. YES MOMENT. YES GO AHEAD
PLEASE. FIFTY ONE RIGHT. WE'RE
ON YES MA'AM GO HEAD THIS IS
OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE. OKAY UP MY NAME IS
JENNIFER CALLING FINAL I LIVE IN
THE CITY OF EL MONTE CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS A LOCK ON YOUR LIST
KALLONI I AM A MOTHER. DOWN AND
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL MA'AM.
YOU DON'T GET THAT SPOTTED
WATCHING THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT CHANGED
A LOT OF THIRD OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL ANYTHING THE
ROCKEFELLERS ARE BANNED BUT
POLLARD THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS KELLY MAKE BAIL AND THAT
SUBSTITUTE FOR TO HIM A COUNTY
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE BILL S. B. ONE FOUR SEVEN
NINE AND I ALSO THINK IS THAT
CLOSE TO A THOUSAND PARENTS
SITTING IN MY COUNTY THE ONLY
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT. FINANCING
FROM M. OKAY THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN PEOPLE AT. MARLENA
TO FRAME I'M FROM SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY AND I AM IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE TWO TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWENTY SIX YES. HI MY
NAME IS LAUREN AMERICANS I AM A
MEMBER I MEAN A VOTER IN SENATOR
DODD DISTRICT AND I AM CLOSE AND
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT MA'AM
WE ARE ONLY AT THIS POINT WE'RE
ONLY TAKING YOUR NAME. OKAY
MISTER MODERATOR- THANK YOU
MA'AM THAT FOR YOUR OPPOSITION
COULD WE GET TO THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINETY ONE EIGHTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS MONIQUE
VERDIN I AM FROM SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY I REFINEMENT CHEAT YOU'RE
HERE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
DISCRIMINATORY BILL THINK
YOU'RE- THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. FIND TO TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD- YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KENNETH
CHORDAL I AM AND THE CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE COUNTY NOT REPRESENTED
MY FAMILY AND I PEOPLE DON'T
NEED TO BE DEMOCRATS AND I
OPPOSE SB ONE FOUR SEVEN NINE.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHTY SEVEN YEAR ONE IS OPEN.
IT WILL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD I'M SORRY. ONE
ZERO THREE ONE ZERO THREE. TWO
SEVENTEEN TWO SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOU MIGHT WANT TO NOT
A VALID PRESIDENT. ON EVERYBODY
MIGHT CHILDREN AND I FAMILY
APPROACH AT NEW PORT. SEVENTY
NINE. THANK YOU SO MUCH COLOR
PLEASE. FIND EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO IS IT ME YES THAT'S
YOU MA'AM GO HEAD. HI MY NAME'S
JENNIFER BANJA I AM A MOTHER AND
I RESIDE IN CINEMA COUNTY AND I
BECAUSE- AT FIFTY ONE FOUR SEVEN
NINE. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE TWO ONE FIVE
TO FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS LAUREN BECAME HER
BACK ON THE MOTHER OF A
KINDERGARTNER IN THE LAFAYETTE
SCHOOL DISTRICT. IN THE GLAZER
STRUCK I STRONGLY OPPOSE WELL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND TWO TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY CRABTREE AND I
REPRESENT NOR CAL FREEDOM
ALLIANCE IN ADDITION TO MY
FAMILY AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE IN JUST SO
EVERYBODY KNOWS WE CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE CALLING IN
IN OPPOSITION JUST SO YOU'RE
AWARE GO AHEAD WITH THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE TWO ONE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT WHEN THE
MONETARY AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE TO THIRTY
FOUR TO ADD. HI MY NAME IS
MICHELLE COLE AND I'M LOOKING
COUNTY AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF ALL THE TEARS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
CAN'T RESIDE IN OFFICE AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR OPPOSITION MA'AM-
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE TO
THIRTY FIVE CHIU CHOI HAS. YEAH
HI YES MA'AM WE CAN HEAR YOU
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE TO
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD.
IT'S FINE FIFTY FIVE ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI FINACLE LITTLEFIELD
OPPOSE THIS OVERREACH THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
TWO ZERO FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT IT WOULD BE WITH THE PARTY
FROM THE GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA
AND I COMPLETELY AFFORDABLE
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE TO
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M CALLING TO REPRESENT DANIEL
MACKINNON MY SAN JUAN PUBLIC
SCHOOL HUSBAND TEACHER THERE'S A
REASON YOU SEE ME IN THAT
BUILDING I AM NOT MA'AM. OKAY
MISTER MODERATE AND EVEN WHEN
YOU GO ON TO THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THAT I'M SO SORRY I KNOW
PEOPLE HAVE THINGS THEY WANT TO
SAY BUT AT THIS POINT IN THE
TESTIMONY IT'S GOTTA BE YOUR
NAME WHO YOU REPRESENT IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. TWO FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY TWO
ZERO THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
VERY PROUD BECAUSE I'M A MOTHER
WITH CALIFORNIA FREEDOM KEEPERS
AND AYE OPPOSED ITSELF THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE TO THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
HEATHER RAY I'M A CONCERNED
PARENT AND RESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER. ONE TWO SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
ERIN SHEEDY I'M FROM NEVADA IN
MARIN COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB ONE. I HAVE A
DISTURBING YOU THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. PINE TO
TWENTY FOUR WEEKS AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS SET THE DOCTOR MON
AND THE CONCERNED MOTHER A FAR
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER. ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHTY SEVEN
YEAR ONE IS OPEN. HEY TO SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS JENNIFER CARMAX AND I
REPRESENT- PARENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE AGAINST THIS
BILL I OPPOSE THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE TO
SEVENTY FOUR FOR IT.
SEVENTY FOUR YEAR ONE IS OPEN.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JULIE HOLYOKE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
ONE ZERO THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES MA'AM GO
HEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS TINA HORN
CO FOUNDER OF PLEASURE COUNTY
PARENTS FOR CHOICE AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY THREE AT.
THANK TWO EIGHTY THREE PLEASE
READ. HI MY NAME IS BOOK LATER
ON- APPARENTLY CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER. ONE
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS THE
RIGHT NUMBER THREE I REPRESENT A
GROUP OF PARENTS WHO DISTRICTS
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY WHO HAD
BEEN OPENED- DIFFERENT HIGHER
TIME ABOUT MANDATORY TESTING AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
TO NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI NICOLE GOOD FELLOW I'M A
LOS ANGELES COUNTY PARENT AND
FORMER LIFELONG DEMOCRAT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FINE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS KELLY CAMERA SO I'M WITH
THE FAMILY YOU KNOW COUNTY
PATRIOT AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MEXICO LINE FIFTY
FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CHRIS PEOPLE PARENT OF TW
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. TRYING TO NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD- HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN GO AHEAD
. THANK YOU FOR CALLING CARD
FROM SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA. I'M
HERE REPRESENTING MY GORGEOUS
WIFE AND OUR BEAUTIFUL KIDS AND
I AM VOICING MY OPPOSITION TO
THIS ILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. PINE TWO
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU TERRY FOR HUMANS OPEN. HELLO YES MA'AM GO HEAD HERE
YOU. GO AHEAD MA'AM YES I'M
CALLING IN REPRESENTING THE
PARENTS TO CALIFORNIA WE WANT
CAN REMOVE TODAY OKAY MA'AM THIS
IS AMANDA ORDER MA'AM MA'AM THIS
IS- YOUR NAME WHO YOU REPRESENT
IN YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
ONLY. MA'AM HEY THERE NO OKAY
NEXT CALLER. WHAT A ONE THREE
ZERO TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS PMR THAT I AM OPPOSING.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE THREE ZERO FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I AM FINE
FOR CATHOLIC FAMILIES OF FREEDOM
IN OAKLAND AND WE OPPOSE ITSELF
. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER.
NINETY TWO NINETY FOUR. HI MY
NAME IS NICOLE CARDANO I AM A
TEACHER IN SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT I'M ALSO
APPEARING AS Q. AND STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER. TRIBECA LINE FIFTY
FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
FORTY EIGHT MOTHER EARTH ISSUE
AT LDN FOR CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS STILL THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER. BY TWO THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
MA'AM GO HEAD. YES I THINK WE
GOT CUT OFF I AM CALLING ON ALL
THE PARENTS ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
PARENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE DONE WITH PAN
WE DO NOT MA'AM MA'AM MA'AM.
MA'AM MY TAX DOLLARS THANK YOU.
OKAY SO- MODERATOR WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO GO TO THE NEXT COLOR
I WAS I GUESS SHE DIDN'T HEAR ME
WHEN I WAS EXPLAINING- HOW THE
TESTIMONY WAS GOING TO GO SAID
COLLEGE ICE FOR THAT WE CAN GO
TO THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OKAY
AND- WILL BE. WINE. BUT IT'S
COMING UP NINE THREE ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE BILL YEAH
HI MY NAME IS EMILY PAYING I AM
FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY I'M
REPRESENTING THE CHILDREN-
FUTURE CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE IT. THANK YOU MA'AM- NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. OKAY IN ONE
GESTURED UP JUST MOMENTS.
OKAY AND- OAKWORTH FINE THREE
ZERO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS AMERICA AND WE OPPOSE
COMMUNISM. THANK YOU MA'AM AS TO
WHY NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OKAY IN
LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
RACHEL RAY FROM RIVERSIDE
CALIFORNIA POSTED STILL. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND HERE WE HAVE NO I DON'T
THINK YOU AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR THAT.
THAT CONCLUDES THE TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION VIA THE PHONE LINES.
TODAY FOR SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE SO THAT BRINGS US NOW- UP
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS DOES ANY.
COMMITTEE MEMBER HAVE A QUESTION
OR COMMENT. MISS GROVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I DO
HAVE A COUPLE COMMENTS OR HAVE A
COMMENT THAT I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FIRST I WOULD ACTUALLY
LIKE TO BRING- THE GOOD DOCTOR
WHO LED THE TESTIMONY UP TO THE
pOF QUESTIONS. AND YOU WERE GOING
TO TALK ABOUT LONG COATED AB. IN
YOUR TIME WAS CUT OFF BECAUSE I
HEARD YOU SAY LONG COVERT IN THE
MISS MELINDA'S BECAUSE OF THE
TIME CONSTRAINTS THE COMMITTEE
CAN YOU ELABORATE ON WHAT YOU'RE
GONNA SAY. TO SET A CURIOSITY.
SURE I'M HAPPY IT. IS ON. YES
SIR. I'M I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
FURTHER QUESTIONS AS WELL BUT I
MEAN I'LL KEEP IT BRIEF I THINK
THERE ARE A LOT OF PARENTS
AROUND THIS COUNTRY MAYBE AROUND
THE WORLD WHO ARE. UNFAIRLY
TERRORIZED- BY CERTAIN REPORTS
ABOUT WHAT LONG COVE IT IS WHAT
IT REPRESENTS. AND I THINK MANY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE CHOSEN TO TAKE
THE VACCINE AND PROTECT
THEMSELVES OR LOW RISK OR HAVE
PRIOR INFECTION ARE STILL
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS POSSIBILITY
AND I THINK IT'S GOOD PUBLIC
HEALTH COMMUNICATION TO FOCUS ON
THE DATA. AND FOCUS ON NOT
SCARING PEOPLE THAT REASSURING
THEM WITH REASSURING DATA WE
HAVE AND- NOW I CAN GO TO THE
LIST BUT THERE LARGE DATASETS
FROM DENMARK ENGLAND- THE
NETHERLANDS FRANCE THAT
BASICALLY SHOW FOR THE LARGE
PART. DIMS RESOLVE- FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE SYMPTOMS THE SYMPTOMS
THAT ARE MOST CONSISTENTLY SEEN.
THAT ARE SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT
TO CONTROL GROUPS AND CONTROL
GROUPS THAT NEVER TESTED
POSITIVE FOR SARS COMMITTEE
MEETING NEVER TESTED POSITIVE
FOR COVE IT. IS ANOSMIA MEANING
LACK OF SMALL WHICH CAN PERSIST
FOR A FEW MONTHS AND WE KNOW
THAT'S BECAUSE THE VIRUS TARGETS
SOME OF THOSE RECEPTORS. BUT
EVEN THAT RESOLVES. AND IT'S
VERY REASSURING AND WHAT'S MORE
IMPORTANT IS THAT. YOU KNOW
SINCE TWENTY TWENTY WE'VE HAD.
MENDIS AWARENESS OF VIRAL
ILLNESS AS IF IT WASN'T PRESENT.
PRIOR TO TWENTY TWENTY UNIT HAS
BEEN AND WE HAVE SOME VERY GOOD
DATA FROM- THE OTHER ONES IN
PARTICULAR WAVE MIND ELECTRONIC
HEALTH RECORD DATA TO LOOK AT.
WHAT IS THE PERSISTENCE OF
SYMPTOMS AFTER WALKER IDEA VIRAL
ILLNESSES THAT WE FACE ALL THE
TIME SUCH AS INFLUENZA. AND IT'S
ABOUT THE SAME. AND THEY LOOKED
AT OVER EIGHTY MILLION
ELECTRONIC RECORDS AND THEY
LOOKED AT TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
FOUR THOUSAND CALL THE PATIENTS
IN COMPARISON. AND SENT THANK
YOU. I KNOW THERE'S SOME OTHER
QUESTIONS THAT I HAD- FOR YOU
BUT YOU AS SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS
THAT ONE FOR ME I KNOW IT WAS
THAT CURIOUS ABOUT THE ACTUAL
SURVEY. THAT WAS CITED BY DR
PANS GROUP. IT WAS ALSO VERY
INTERESTED IN YOUR COMMENT- THAT
YOU MADE THAT YOU HAVE A- NO
WHAT WAS THE EXACT WORD YOU USE
YOU HAVE- NO COMPELLING. IN THIS
YOUR BOARD CERTIFIED PHYSICIAN
CORRECT REPORTS CERTIFIED
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN I'VE BEEN
PRACTICING FOR MORE THAN. TWENTY
ONE YEARS NOW OKAY I APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU SIR VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. I DO HAVE I'M
JUST A STATEMENT THAT I'D LIKE
TO MAKE AND I'D LIKE TO ASK THEM
THE AUTHOR AND I'M SORRY CENTER
YOU WANT ME TO COMMENT ON THE
STUDY FOR THE STATUS SERVING- IF
YOU HAVE A BRIEF COMMENT ON THE
STUDY SURVEY THAT WAS BROUGHT
FORTH THEN YES THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING I'D LIKE YOU TO DO AS
WELL. I DO- YOU KNOW I THINK ONE
OF THE POINTS I WAS TRYING TO
MAKE IS IF YOU LOOK AT THE
PERFORMANCE OF THESE TESTS EVEN
MANAGING TEST WHICH HONESTLY
GOOD LET HOME ALTERNATIVE RATHER
THAN PCR WHICH CAN BE OVERLY
SENSITIVE. IS THAT. GIVEN THE
PERFORMANCE STATISTICS AND WE
CAN GO THROUGH WHAT I MEAN BY
THAT. I THINK THAT'S YOU KNOW
GETTING THE WEEDS. BUT
CALIFORNIA HAD BASICALLY SEVEN
WEEKS WITHIN THE LAST FIFTY TWO
WEEKS WERE FALSE POSITIVES WOULD
HAVE BEEN LOWER THAN TRUE
POSITIVES MEANING FALSE POSITIVE
WOULD BE SITUATIONS WHERE
CHILDREN OTHER PEOPLE WOULD BE
SENT HOME. UNNECESSARILY EVEN
THOUGH THEY WERE NOT TRULY
INFECTED. AND THAT PERIOD OF
TIME WAS ROUGHLY AROUND DECEMBER
TWENTY SECOND I THINK YOU
FEBRUARY SEVENTH I HAVE IN MY
NOTES. BUT THAT'S THE ONLY
PERIOD OF TIME WHERE THE TRUE
POSITIVES WITH X. WOULD HAVE
EXCEEDED THE INAPPROPRIATE
POSITIVE SO TO SPEAK. AND IN THE
STUDY CITED- BY- SOME OF THE
PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL. THEY'RE
TESTING POSITIVITY RATE WAS ZERO
POINT 1% I TOLD YOU THIS WOULD
BREAK IT 7% SEVEN AND A HALF
ACTUALLY. TO BUY THEIR- OWN
SURVEY. A SEVEN HUNDRED AND 50%
DIFFERENTIAL OF FALSE POSITIVES
TO TRUE POSITIVES WOULD HAVE
BEEN PRESENT BY THEIR OWN DATA
NOW THAT'S OFTEN FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BY THE WAY IT'S NOT
EVEN CURRENT WITH OMICRON WHICH
IS A VERY DIFFERENT SITUATION.
AS ABOUT 50% OF CALIFORNIAN
HOUSEHOLDS FOUND OUT IN THOSE
FOSTER POSITIVES WOULD REQUIRE
KIDS TO BE OUT OF SCHOOL FOR IT
THAT'S CORRECT HAND YOU KNOW THE
I THINK WAS MS VASES DAVE I'M
SORRY SHE'S A PHYSICIAN I DON'T
KNOW WHERE TO TITLE WAS BUT SHE
BROUGHT UP. SOMETHING ABOUT THE
BERKELEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN RAVENS WHAT I MEAN I PRACTICE
IN A HOSPITAL THAT'S RECEIVING
FACILITY FOR MANY PATIENTS FROM
RAVENS WITH. SO WHATEVER TESTING
WAS DONE THERE THAT HELPED THEM
GET ACCESS THAT'S WONDERFUL BUT
I SAW A LOT OF FAMILIES IN THE
BILL A LOT OF IN THE PEDIATRIC
ER EXPRESSLY FOR SPECIFICS
PRESLEY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
GETTING TESTS AND- IT DIDN'T
MITIGATE THAT. AND I THINK
WHAT'S INTERESTING TO AND-
BECAUSE YOU BROUGHT UP THE
BERKELEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
ISSUED DAMAGE DONE. IS A FATHER
IN THE DISTRICT TO REACHED OUT
TO ME. AND HIS SON. HE'S
FOURTEEN I WAS PERMISSION TO
REVEAL IS BY THE WAY I HAVE AS
PERMISSION TO SHARE THIS. IN THE
MAIL THIS IS REGARDING THE STUDY
THOUGH SIR BECAUSE NO IT'S NOT
ACTUALLY IT'S REGARDING HIS
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AND WHAT
HAPPENED WITH HIS PERSONAL RISK
HIS REQUEST FOR INFORMATION TO
THE DISTRICT. AND HIS SON IS A
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD WHO WAS.
ACCIDENT AND WAS STRUCK BY AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD WHO. WAS
STRIKING HIM FOR THE REASON THAT
HE WAS ON VACCINATED. YOU KNOW I
STRONGLY SUPPORT- VACCINATION I
REALLY DO AFFECTED VACCINATIONS. IN THE RIGHT POPULATIONS FOR
SURE. BUT- THE OTHER RING AND
THE VICTORY ALL FOR NO CLEAR
BENEFIT REALLY BOTHERS ME- AS A
PHYSICIAN AND THE CITIZENS AN
APPARENT. AND IN HIS PUBLIC
REQUESTS TO THE BERKELEY SCHOOL
DISTRICT FROM JANUARY FOURTH TO
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH FORTY FIVE
OF FIFTY SEVEN OF THE STUDENTS
THAT TESTED POSITIVE IN THE
DISTRICT WERE VACCINATED. THANK
YOU SIR I APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN I JUST HAVE
A STATEMENT- THAT I'D LIKE TO
MAKE AN AND- I MEAN ALL OF US
RATE THAT SERVE THE UNITED
STATES MILITARY LIKE I SAID I
THINK THERE'S FOUR OF US MAYBE
FIVE OF US. ALSO BECAUSE I DON'T
REQUIRE I DON'T RECALL BUT TO
THERE'S FOUR OF US DEFINITELY-
WE TOOK THE OATH OF OFFICE TO
SWEAR TO DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION
THE UNITED STATES AGAINST ALL
ENEMIES FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC.
AND WE ALWAYS AS MY COLLEAGUE IN
STOCKTON IS WHISPERING IN MY EAR
WE ALSO TAKE EVERY VACCINE THAT
WAS REQUIRED OF US WHICH WE DID.
UNITED STATES MILITARY. I
REMEMBER GOING THROUGH THAT LINE
I'M SURE JUST LIKE SHE'D. WITH
THOSE OF THIS AIR- BUT- ED THE
CON. WHICH I'M GOING TO DO GO
THROUGH WHICH ALL OF US SHOULD
HAVE. LIKE THERE
ARE OF US ARE THE DAIS IDEA WE
DON'T. BUT THE CONCERT. IS
HIGHEST LAW. IN AND HAS SOME.
KNOWS A BILL OVER. IN THE OF
RIGHTS OR CENTER FOR. RIGHTS
DURING. THE FREEDOM RELIGION
SPEECH. TO AND OTHER THINGS. BUT
THEM. ALL OF OUR CHILDREN ARE
PROTECTED. FOR EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
IN EDUCATION NO MATTER WHAT
THEIR RACE ETHNIC BACKGROUND
RELIGION SEX. OR WHETHER THEY'RE
RICH OR POOR CITIZEN AND
NONCITIZEN. AND WHEN YOU GET THE
DEFINITION BACKGROUND BASED ON
THE CONSTITUTION. IT SAYS ANY
BACKGROUND. AND IT'S NOT JUST.
IT IN THE BACKGROUND AS AND A
DEFINITION THERE. THAT ANY ANY
PERSON AND THEY HAVE TO HAVE
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESS TO
THE EDUCATION SYSTEM THAT THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM PROVIDED
BY THE GOVERNMENT. OR THE STATE.
EXIST AND- TO LIMIT THEIR
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
SCHOOL OR DO ANYTHING UNLESS
THEY COMPLY WITH RULES. THAT ARE
SET FORTH BY THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY. IS A VIOLATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION EVERY YEAR THAT WE
GET ELECTED WE SWEAR TO DEFEND
THE CONSTITUTION- THE OTHER
THING IS THAT. THESE PARENTS
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO CO PARENT
WITH GOVERNMENT. THEY SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO AND COMPLY WITH THIS IF
YOU HAVE IF YOU WANT AND YOU'VE
DONE THE RESEARCH AND YOU WANT
YOUR CHILD TO BE FULLY
VACCINATED AND BOOSTED. THAT IS
YOUR RIGHT AND NO ONE OUT IN THE
HALLWAY SHOULD EVER SAY ANYTHING
TO YOU ABOUT IT. BUT IF YOU
WORRY PARENT THAT HAS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE VACCINE OR ANY VACCINE
OR ANYTHING INJECTED IN YOUR
CHILD THEN YOU HAVE EVERY RIGHT.
TO REPRESENT THE INTEREST OF
YOUR CHILD IT'S YOUR CHILD AND
SO I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION AND ANY OTHER
LEGISLATION THAT COMES FORWARD.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
AUTHOR TO- YOU KNOW ADDRESS OR
LISTEN TO THE PARENTS THAT HAVE
HUGE CONCERNS AND I THINK HE
DOES BUT TO RESPECT. THEIR
RIGHTS JUST AS WHEN THEY CAME
INTO THIS BUILDING- SOME OF THE
THINGS THEY SAY ABOUT YOU WERE
ALLOWED THIS. APPETITE AS WELL
THEY SHOULD. YOUR OPINION AND
YOUR RIGHTS JUST AS MUCH AS- SIX
BREAK IT RESPECT THEIR OPINIONS
AND THEIR RIGHTS- SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE- SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MADAM BASED HERE I WANT TO
THANK THE- CHAIRS- CENTER PAN
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND- HAPPENED A CO AUTHOR OF
THAT I WANT TO THANK CENTER AND
FOR BEING AN EXTRAORDINARY
LEADER- IN PUBLIC HEALTH- AND
KEEPING OUR COMMUNITY HEALTHY-
AND SAFE AND HE'S BEEN THE
SUBJECT OF. A BRUTAL PERSONAL
ATTACKS INCLUDING PHYSICAL
ASSAULTS- AND HE KEEPS DOING IT
YOU COULD BE DOING A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS AND KEEPS DOING
THIS. FIVE HE CAN ABOUT THIS
COMMUNITY ANY TEARS ABOUT THE
FORTY MILLION RESIDENTS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO- CENTER
POUND THANK YOU FOR. FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP I SUPPORT THIS BILL-
AND I WILL SAY I REPRESENT A
HUGE NUMBER OF OUR PARENTS. IN
MY UNITY WHO. THEY WANT THEIR
KIDS TO BE SAFE AND HEALTHY AT
SCHOOL- AND THEY WANT. TO HAVE
AS MUCH CONFIDENCE AS POSSIBLE-
BECAUSE THEY WANT THEIR KIDS
BACK IN SCHOOL AND I'VE- BEEN A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF KEEPING THE
SCHOOLS OPEN. ORANGE WANT KIDS
PHYSICALLY IN SCHOOL- AND THEY
WANT THEM PHYSICALLY AND TO BE
SAFE- AND TESTING AS PART OF
KEEPING OUR SCHOOLS SAFE- YES
KIDS ARE AT LOWER RISK THAN
ADULTS WHEN IT COMES TO CURB IT
BUT THERE ARE KIDS WHO DO GET
VERY SICK AND HE GOT
HOSPITALIZED EVEN DIE FROM CODE
AND THEY CAN THEN BRING CLOSER
TO HOME. TO A PARENT OR
GRANDPARENT WHO MAY BE MORE
RISK- AND SO TESTING IS A KEY
PART OF ANY PUBLIC HEALTH
STRATEGY- YOU KNOW WE ARE IN A
BETTER PLACE RIGHT NOW WITH CODE
THAT WE WERE A YEAR OR YEAR AND
A HALF AGO THAT'S ABSOLUTELY THE
CASE. BUT WE ARE STILL IN A
PANDEMIC AND YOU CAN'T COMPARE-
THIS- THIS VIRUS JUST LIKE THE
COMMON COLD- THIS IS VERY
DANGEROUS- FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE-
IN TESTING AS PART OF ANY SMART
PUBLIC HEALTH- STRATEGY SO I.
WILL MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR WINNER DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK FROM
THE COMMITTEE SENATOR EGGMAN
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. A DOCTOR PAN. SO THERE WAS
A LOT. LOT OF COMMENTS WILL HURT
AND WE'VE BEEN WE'VE- IS NOT
THIS OUR FIRST TIME- WITH THIS
ISSUE. SO WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF
THINGS IN. AND I FOR ONE AM NOT
A PART OF ANY SECRET SOCIETY NOR
NOR AM I FOR DINAMIC TESTING
FROM CHINA SO. TO SAY THAT
HOWEVER CAN YOU TELL ME JUST ONE
MORE TIME BECAUSE I READ THIS
BILL AND I LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS. AND IT LOOKS TO ME
LIKE THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. IT'S GOING TO
SUPPORT SCHOOLS. AND MAKE SURE
THAT THE TESTING THAT PEOPLE ARE
USING IS- HIS STUDENTS TO THE
SCHOOLS THEMSELVES DON'T HAVE TO
DO THE ACTUAL STEP. UP HERE
CURING VENDORS OF DOING ALL THAT
THEMSELVES THIS IS TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR SCHOOLS TO BE ABLE TO
STAY OPEN THE TEACHER CHILDREN.
BUT I THINK MAYBE MY- COLLEAGUES
FROM TO THE CALIFORNIA HAS
CHILDREN IN. SCHOOL BUT I EXPECT
I AM I AM SOMEONE WHO DIES WHO
AS A CHILD STILL IN THE CASE
TWELVE. AND HAVE BEEN DEALING
WITH THIS- IN THE END I WOULD
SAY A LOT OF TIMES IT'S YOU KNOW
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT FOR A LOT
FROM PEOPLE TO HELP US ALL LEAVE
IT RIGHT THERE. BUT CAN YOU IS
IT IS THIS SOME KIND OF.
SOMETHING IS GOING TO GO IN. AND
BE TESTING CHILDREN EVERY DAY.
TAKING THEM OUT OF SCHOOL
BECAUSE IT LOOKS TO ME. LIKE
IT'S TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
PLANS IN PLACE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
. SO OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEMS CAN STAY OPEN. I CAN USE
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT FOR ME.
THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN FOR THAT
QUESTION REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT'S BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S A
LOT BEING SAID ABOUT THE BILL
THAT ISN'T ACTUALLY IN THE BILL.
SO WHAT THE BILL CALLS FOR IS
THE COST FOR. EACH SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND OTHER ELECTRICAL
PRODUCTS OVER TO HAVE A TESTING
PLAN AND ACTUALLY- WORK WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH WHICH BY THE WAY
WILL BE PROVIDING. ADVICE
SUPPORT RIGHT HE SAID- WE WANTS-
DEFINING SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
INCLUDING TAX ASSISTANCE.
SUPPORT GUIDANCE MONITORING
EVALUATION. XIN SO THE IDEA IS
THAT AND ALSO IT'S- DEPENDING ON
GOING ON IN THE APARTMENT SO
BRING NOW WE'RE LOW BIT A LOT
FOR HALF WE DON'T NEED TO TEST
THIS MUCH WHEN THE CASE. GO UP.
WE NEED TO MORE BECAUSE ULTIMATE
WE WANT TO KEEP. KIDS SAFE IN
SCHOOL IT ALSO PARENTS WANT TO
KNOW. I MEAN THINK ABOUT IT THIS
I MEAN I HAVE CHILDREN IN SCHOOL
MANY OF YOU HAVE CHILDREN IN
SCHOOL- YOU'RE READY GAME THAT
NO SAYING SOMEONE IN THIS CLASS
HAD HEAD LICE RIGHT- BECAUSE
PARENTS WANT TO KNOW NOW HEAD
LICE IS A DEADLY DISEASE. BUT
YEAH SO WHAT'S AND- IS THAT
THERE ARE FAMILIES- THEIR
CHILDREN IN SCHOOL WHO ARE MORE
VULNERABLE TO THE DISEASE. MAY
HAVE DIABETES ASTHMA OTHER
CONDITIONS. THEY MAY HAVE THEY
THEY MAY BE GOING HOME TO A
HOUSEHOLD. AND SO WHERE SOMEONE
MAY BE AT HIGH RISK OF COVERAGE.
SO AGAIN. THIS IS ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY FOR PARENTS THOSE
TWO BECAUSE PARENTS DON'T WANT
THEIR POWER IN FACT. AND KNOW
ABOUT IT. HOME AND THE
POTENTIALLY PUT SOMEONE ELSE IN
DANGER SO. HELPS ENSURE THAT.
APPLICANTS CAN FORM. CASE THEIR
CHOPS SPOKE. TESTING ALLOWS US
TO KNOW WHERE WE'RE GOING. AND
IN TERMS OF THE DISEASE
OUTBREAKS SCHOOL BECAUSE WHAT WE
DON'T WANT TO DO IS. WITHOUT
TESTING IT'S KIND OF LIKE YOU
DON'T. GOING TO GET THIS TEST IS
. BASED ON THE CONDITIONS GOING
ON AND ALSO TO BE SURE THAT- YOU
KNOW WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT DOING
EXCEPT. HE HAD. LEVEL THAT'S
WHAT. WHY PROVIDE A GUIDANCE BUT
ALSO OTHER PART OF IT IS SOME
SAID WELL THIS IS ONLY. WELL
ACTUALLY PART OF THE IS ABOUT
FUNDING APPROPRIATELY OF TESTS
AT SCHOOL SO. YOU KNOW THERE IS
A BUT WE WON'T BE SCHOOL ARE
ABLE DO THE- IS WELL AS WELL. AS
AND- IN SO THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
IS REALLY ABOUT ABOUT SUPPORTING
OUR SCHOOLS. TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN KEEP THEIR
CHILDREN AT SCHOOL SAFE. TO KEEP
SCHOOLS OPEN WE WANT SCHOOLS
CLOSING WOULD LIKE IN PERSON
LEARNING AND ALSO- WE ARE BE
SURE FORTY PARENTS WHO ARE
PAYING IT'S A SCHOOL THE- KNOW.
THAT THE OF. YOU NEED. DON'T
HELP BOOKS. THEIR TRUCK AS WELL
. THIS DOESN'T THIS BILL IS NOT
TO SAY EVERY CHILD IS TO GET TO
IS GONNA SAY IF SOMETHING AT
THIS THE APPROPRIATE P. WILL BE
A PROTOCOL ABOUT WHAT WILL
HAPPEN AND HELP PARENTS WILL BE
NOTIFIED SO YOU SEE COOL THIS IT
CALLED AND BEND IT WILL. AND IT
WILL HAVE TESTING PLANNED-
REQUIRING TO HAVE A TESTING PLAY
AND ALL GET ASSISTANCE THE PART
PUBLIC HEALTH- AND THIS TESTING
PLAN SUCH BE- CONSISTENT WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDELINES.
CORRECT. SENATOR LEYVA GO HEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY BECAUSE I HEARD
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES TALKING
ABOUT VACCINES AND BEING
REQUIRED TO GET VACCINATED. THIS
BILL DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH GETTING VACCINATED CORRECT
NO THIS HAS TO DO WITH HAVING.
AT YOUR MEN THAT. THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT DEVELOP AND SELLS THIS
IS ACTUALLY. SILENT ON ANY
REQUIREMENTS FOR VACCINATION-
FOR KOBE IN SCHOOLS THANK YOU
AND THEN I WAS READING THE
SUMMARY HERE AND IT SAYS
REQUIRES A CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC. CDPH TO CONTINUE.
ADMINISTERING SO THIS IS NOT
EVEN A NEW PROGRAM THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
HAPPENING AT OUR SCHOOLS. OKAY
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE IT'S CLEAR
THAT. THEY'RE NOT JUST ON I
UNDERSTAND THE OPPOSITION TO
BEING TESTED I MEAN WE'VE BEEN
TESTING TWICE A WEEK HERE IN THE
SENATE FOR ABOUT TWO AND A HALF
YEARS. I AM NOT AWARE OF ANY ONE
WHO HAS HAD A FALSE POSITIVE.
AND IT JUST HELPS US KNOW WHAT
IS HAPPENING WHEN- SOMEONE OF MY
GRANDDAUGHTER'S PRESCHOOL TESTED
POSITIVE. THEY CALLED ALL THE
PARENTS TO LET THEM KNOW. PEOPLE
JUST WANT TO KNOW I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANYTHING WRONG WITH
PEOPLE BEING TESTED AND PEOPLE
HAVING KNOWLEDGE. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO VOTING ON THE BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH GO
AHEAD PLEASE IS THE QUICKER
QUESTION I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT I'M CLEAR. SO ARE WE
SETTING THE RULES SOMEBODY USE
THE TERM THE PHRASE RULES AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE I'M CLEAR WE
SETTING THE RULES FOR WHEN
TESTING OCCURS OR IF TESTING
OCCURS OR IS SOME OTHER ENTITIES
SUCH AS THE CDC OR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF. PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPAND SO WE ARE ASKING
THAT EACH SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
THE OTHER ENTITIES SO THERE'S
IT'S LIKE THEY HAVE TO GO FOR
ITS ADDRESS- ACTUALLY DEVELOPED
A TEST YOU KNOW HAVE A TESTING
PLANNED SO THEY NEED TO HAVE ONE
THEY CAN'T JUST NOT HAVE A PLAN
AT ALL IN THAT PLAN. TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF THE HEALTH
GUIDELINES AND OF COURSE WON THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THE OTHER ENTITIES
LAW SCHOOL OF SITUATIONS
ETCETERA TO SEE SEVEN IN TERMS
OF BEING ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THAT
PLAN SO IF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CAN
ANALYZING RECESSING THE CURRENT
IN THIS CASE COVERT. NINETEEN
RATE LEVEL WHATEVER THAT. HEALTH
RELATED TO IS. DETERMINES THAT
NO TESTING. IS REQUIRED IN THE
K. THROUGH TWELVE OPERATION IN
CALIFORNIA. DOES THAT MEAN A LOT
OF- LOCAL EDUCATIONAL THIRTY A
SCHOOL DISTRICT WOULD NOT HAVE
TO- MINUTES TESTING PLAN. YES IF
WE IF THAT TURNS OUT WE ARE ABLE
TO GET THE CASE RATE OF COATED
LOW ENOUGH- THEN- TESTING MAY BE
UNNECESSARY AND- THAT'S- AND
THAT MAY BE THE RECOMMENDATION
CORRECT AND THAT'S WITHIN THE
PURVIEW OF THE- CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. NOT
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY THAT'S
CORRECT YES THANK YOU. OKAY I
THINK THAT'S EVERYONE NOW SO IT
IS MY TURN- SO IT LOOKS TO ME AS
THOUGH IT DOES. THE BILL DOES
REQUIRE THAT A PLAN IS IN PLACE
AND THAT TESTING- TAKE PLACE SO. OKAY CALIFORNIA NATIONWIDE.
AND I THINK WE HAVE 12% OF THE
STUDENTS IN THE COUNTRY AND WE
ONLY HAD 1% OF A SCHOOL CLOSURES
BECAUSE OF COPING. SO THAT SEEMS
A BIT DISPROPORTIONATE AND I
THINK WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THE
DATA HAS SHOWN THAT- THESE HOME
TESTS. AREN'T ALWAYS- AS
EFFECTIVE AS WE WOULD LIKE AND I
HAVE A PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH
THAT AS DO OTHER MEMBERS OF MY
FAMILY- THE HOME TESTS JUST.
THEY'RE JUST NOT AS EFFECTIVE
YOU CAN HAVE CODED AND THEN YOU
KNOW IT DOESN'T SHOW POSITIVE
FOR FIVE DAYS SO. REALLY WHAT
ARE WE MITIGATING IF A STUDENT
STATE TEST NEGATIVE- BUT
ACTUALLY HAS COVE AND INCOMES TO
SCHOOL ANYWAY- NOT TO MENTION
THE FACT THAT. THE FOCUS IS ON
ON KIDS FOR TESTING THEM BUT
WHAT WE'RE NOT TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT HIS. THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THEIR FAMILY THEIR PARENTS
ARE PERHAPS THEIR OLDER SIBLINGS
OR GRANDPARENTS TO LIVE WITH
THEM WHO ARE GOING OUT IN IN
BEING IN A PUBLIC SETTING AND
PERHAPS YOU KNOW THEY'RE
BRINGING AND HOW WE'D I DON'T
THINK THAT WE CAN PINPOINT- THAT
THAT. INFECTION NECESSARILY TOOK
PLACE AT THE SCHOOL NOT TO
MENTION. AS SYMPTOMATIC TESTING
OF STUDENTS. WE HAVE SEEN JUST.
REALLY DOESN'T PROVIDE ANY
MITIGATING EFFECT I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S DATA WE HAVE. THE- ON
HERE. OKAY SO THE- THERE IS A
COMPANY THE COLOR COMPANY I
THINK IT'S CALLED THEY DID A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
RAPID TEST MUCH LIKE THE ONES
THAT WE TAKE LEGISLATORS EVERY
SUNDAY BEFORE WE COME UP HERE TO
SACRAMENTO AND THEN WE TAKE
ANOTHER ONE- ON WEDNESDAYS THEY
DID HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND OF
THESE RAPID TESTS- ONLY SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE OF
THOSE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND TEST- SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE OF THEM SHOWED
POSITIVE. OF THE 600-233-0080
FIVE OF THEM ONE SEEDED A
FURTHER PCR TEST WHICH IS THE
GOLD STANDARD ONLY THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE OF THEM- I'M SORRY
EXCUSE ME THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE OF THEM TURNED OUT TO BE
NEGATIVE THEY DIDN'T HAVE
COVERAGE. SO I MEAN THAT'S NOT
HYPERBOLE THAT'S JUST THE FACT
THAT THESE TESTS ARE JUST NOT
1100% ACTIVE- ACCURATE. IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT'S OUT THERE
SUGGEST THAT THESE TESTS ARE
MISSING ABOUT A THIRD OF THOSE
WHO ARE INFECTED WITH THIS VIRUS
IN KIDS AT THIRD SO WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS AND I'VE SEEN IN MY
OWN KIDS- SCHOOLS BECAUSE I DO
STILL HAVE CHILDREN IN SCHOOL
MYSELF. OR MY OWN CHILD GOT SENT
HOME BECAUSE HE COST IT'S COOL.
LEADING TO A TEST AND SO HE HAD
A QUARANTINE AND THEN THERE WERE
SOMEONE ELSE AT SCHOOL HAD
QUARANTINE. BECAUSE THERE IS A
POSITIVE TEST IN TURNS OUT THAT
STUDENT DID NOT HAVE CODED SO
NOW THEY'VE MISSED EVEN MORE
INSTRUCTION AND TO ME IT'S- TO
THE POINT F ABSURDITY NOW WHAT
WE'RE DOING TODAY IS TO THESE
KIDS YOU CANNOT KEEP REMOVING
THEM FROM THE CLASSROOM
ENVIRONMENT AFTER WHERE HE DID
THAT TO THEM FOR MORE THAN A
YEAR AND EXPECT THEM TO BE
LEARNING IN A WAY THAT'S GOING
TO HELP THEM SUCCEED AND THRIVE
AND BE ABLE TO PASS THE TESTING
GOING TO WHATEVER IT IS THEY
GOING TO AFTER HIGH SCHOOL- IT.
YOU KNOW I GET IT WE ALL WANT TO
BE SAFE FROM CALVIN WE DO BUT
IT'S THIS OBSESSION WITH
FOCUSING ON KIDS I JUST THINK
NEEDS TO STOP- NOT TO MENTION. I
GUESS THE ONE THING WE DIDN'T
TALK ABOUT WAS. YOU KNOW WHEN
THESE KIDS ARE REMOVED FROM THE
SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY HAVE TESTED
POSITIVE IN MAYBE IT'S A FALSE
POSITIVE MAYBE IT'S AN ACTUAL
POSITIVE OR THEY'VE BEEN EXPOSED
TO SOMEBODY IN THE CLASSROOM AND
SO THEY DECIDE THIS. JOHN HAS TO
QUARANTINE. WHY IS THERE NO
FOCUSED ON WHAT THAT CHILD IS
DOING WHEN THEY'RE NOT IN THE
CLASSROOM. BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS
ARE PROBABLY HOPEFULLY WORKING-
WHY NO FOCUS ON THAT WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THAT CHILD
BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN THE DAMAGE
THAT HAS BEEN DONE
PSYCHOLOGICALLY TO THESE KIDS
FROM BEING PULLED OUT OF THEIR
CLASSROOMS FOR MORE THAN A YEAR
COMPUTER. THE DAMAGES THAT WE
JUST HAD A BILL TALKING ABOUT
THE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE AND
WANTING TO HAVE MORE FUNDING FOR
WE CANNOT IGNORE WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN WE KEEP THIS SYSTEM IN
PLACE. OF BEING ABLE TO REMOVE
KIDS FROM THE CLASSROOM. WITH
KEVIN TESTING AND NOT TALK ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU DO THAT- I. I'M SORRY I CANNOT SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY AND I DEEPLY
RESPECT- THE INTENT. BEHIND
TRYING TO KEEP EVERYBODY SAFE
BUT THIS BILL JUST IT DOESN'T DO
THAT AND I WISH THAT WE COULD
STOP WITH THIS OBSESSION OF
GOING AFTER KIDS WHO CAN'T STAND
UP FOR THEMSELVES BECAUSE THEIR
KIDS WELL THAT'S WHAT I WAS
PERRANCE HERS. AND THAT'S WHAT
I'M GOING TO DO SO RESPECTFULLY-
I CANNOT VOTE FOR THIS BILL SO
WITH THAT MISTER OR DOCTOR PAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE HER BIG
WIN COME. OF COURSE SENATOR
ROUGHLY ZERO I'VE HEARD THE
STATEMENT THAT THE BILL REQUIRES
TESTING AND- YOU KNOW MAYBE.
MAYBE THAT'S ONE INTERPRETATION
OF ITBUT YOU KNOW BEING. THE
FORMER LAWYER THAT I AM I HAVE
TO READ. THE LANGUAGE OF THIS
BILL SIMPLY SAYS THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
SHALL CONTINUE ADMINISTERING
THOSE COVERT TESTING PROGRAMS IN
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
SHALL ADMINISTER A TESTING
PROGRAM SO THAT MAY REQUIRE.
SOME LEVEL OF TESTING WE CLEAR
OTHERWISE OR MAY NOT DEPENDING
ON THE GUIDANCE ISSUED BY THE-
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
I JUST THINK WE OUGHTA WELL MAKE
THAT. CLARIFICATION AND THEN THE
NEXT. WIND DOWN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
SHALL ADMINISTER TESTING
PROGRAMS WELL IT DOESN'T SAY
TEST MINISTRY TESTING PROGRAM.
SO TO BE CLEAR. ADMINISTERING A
TESTING PROGRAM PURSUANT TO A
PLAN. MAY REQUIRE TESTING TO
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH SAYS FOR THE CDC
OR IT MAY NOT SO I THINK WE
OUGHT TO. JUST MAKE SURE WE KNOW
WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON THANK YOU
SENATOR ROTH AND JUST I MEAN I
UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM BUT IN MY INTERPRETATION
AND UNDERSTANDING OF THE BILL IT
GIVES ITS STATUTORY PERMANENCE
SO THAT MEANS THEN THAT IT'S A
VERY ACROSS THE STATE THERE IS
NO CONSISTENCY AND THAT'S
FRANKLY THE LAST THING- THAT WE
WANT TO DO BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS DR PAN DID YOU
WANT TO CLOSE. I'M SORRY DID YOU
HAVE COMMENTS. GLIMCHER HELLO
YES GO AHEAD I APOLOGIZE I
FORGET HOW THAT'S OKAY WE HAVE
CENTER GONZALEZ PLEASE GETTING
VERY MUCH- MADAM CHAIR I JUST
WANNA- TO REITERATE MY THANKS TO
A DOCTOR PAN FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I MYSELF HAVE A YOUNG
ONE IN K. THROUGH TWELVE- HE HAD
BEEN TESTING SINCE FOR THE LAST
YEAR HE DID RANDOM TESTS HE DID
TEST WEEKLY WE HAVE A AT HOME
TEST IT'S A VARIETY OF THINGS
THAT THAT- THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT MY SON GOES TO HAD HAS
DONE. ALL TO KEEP OTHER STUDENTS
AND PARENTS SAFE MY FATHER TAKES
CARE OF MY SON AFTER WORK
BECAUSE CLEARLY I'M HERE IN
SACRAMENTO I WANT TO KEEP HIM
SAFE AS WELL WE NEED TO KNOW SO
FOR ME- THE TESTING MY SIX YEAR
OLD HASN'T EVEN COMPLAINED ONCE
IT'S FORTUNATE THAT WERE IN THIS
TIME WE'RE WE'RE CHILDREN ARE
ACCUSTOMED TO THIS TYPE OF
RIGOROUS TESTING- VACCINES IN
HEARING ABOUT DEATH AND IT'S
TOUGH AND I KNOW THAT AS A
PARENT MYSELF. BUT FOR ME- I
KNOW THAT IT'S KEEPING OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE AND AT THE END OF
THE DAY- AGAIN TO REITERATE
SENATOR POINT MODERATE. NOT
EVERY A HUNDRED STUDENTS ARE
GOING TO BE TESTED DOESN'T MEAN
IT'S GOING TO BE EVERY SINGLE
DAY CAN BE WERE A VARIETY OF
THINGS CUSTOMIZED FOR THAT
REGION AGAIN WITH THE GOAL OF
KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE SO THAT AS
SUPPORT THANK. THANK DR PAN.
THANK YOU AND APPRECIATE THAT'S
AND FROM ALL OF YOU ON THE
COMMITTEE- BUT IT'S MAKING A
FIFTY THREE POINTS- SELF FIRST
OF ALL- TESTING RECOMMENDATIONS
DEPENDS ON LOCAL CIRCUMSTANCES
SO THERE'S A KIND OF A
CONSISTENCY WELL BECAUSE OF CFC
BASED ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES RIGHT
SO IF WE HAVE A HIGHER CASE OF
KOBE. AND I DO I REITERATE IT IS
A SERIOUS DISEASE ALL RIGHT THIS
IS NOT A DISEASE BE TAKEN
LIGHTLY- YEAH WE HAD A WHOLE
HEARING ON LONG COVE IT AND I
APPRECIATE THAT SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES WERE PRESENT THERE
AND SAID YOU KNOW WE SHOULD
BELIEVE THE PEOPLE WHO TELL.
TELL TOLD US THAT FONG COVERED
SERIOUS RIGHT THAT THAT THE ONE
TO ADDICTS YOU EXPERIENCED.
SUGAR STORIES WITH US. THAT YOU
WE JUST A TESTING. BASED ON
CIRCUMSTANCES RIGHT SO IF
THERE'S A LOT OF. COOLEY GOING
ON IN THE COMMUNITY- AND YOUR
INCREASE IN SCHOOL THEN YOU'RE
PREGNANT TEST MORE FREQUENTLY IN
THE MORE CERVANTES THINK IF THAT
GOES DOWN. SO AND PERHAPS EVEN
NOT RIGHT BECAUSE THAT'S THE
CASE THREE THREE THREE LOW AND
SO WE WANT TO HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY- WE WANT TO ACTUALLY
WE LET EACH SCHOOL DISTRICT.
SIMILAR TESTING PLAN WE DIDN'T
DICTATE TO THEM EXACTLY WHAT IT
IS I DIDN'T I'M NOT TRYING TO.
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE
LEGISLATION SO THAT LEGISLATORS
IS VERY SPECIFIC REGIMENTED BY
LAW IN THE CODE TESTING PLANS
AND SAID WE HAVE TO WORK WITH
THE FARM PUBLIC HEALTH ON THAT-
I. ALSO WANT NOTE- THE TERM OF
THAT YOU KNOW WE DON'T WANT TO
SPEAK. FROM SCHOOLS. RIGHT AND I
DON'T KEEP IN MIND THAT THERE
ARE CHILDREN WHO ARE CURRENTLY
NOT ATTENDING SCHOOL BECAUSE
THEIR PARENTS ARE WORRIED THAT
THE SCHOOLS THEMSELVES AND NOT
SAFE ENOUGH FOR THEIR CHILD.
THEY'RE WORRIED THEIR CHILD'S
GOING TO GET SICK OR THEIR
CHILD'S GONNA BRING IT HOME TO
SOMEONE THEIR HOUSEHOLD. HE'S
GONNA GET REALLY SEPARATE
SOMEONE WITH DIABETES SO IT HAS
OF SOMEONE WHO'S STRIPPING FREE
OR CANCER- SOMEONE. WITH A
CHRONIC CONDITION. AND I THINK
WE NEED TO LISTEN TO THOSE
PARENTS. AS WELL BECAUSE THEY'RE
AFRAID TO SEND THEIR KIDS TO
SCHOOL AND WE WANT TO BE SURE
SCHOOLS ARE. OPEN AND SAFE FOR
THEM AS WELL. AND THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT- I WOULD ALSO JUST
WANT TO MENTION THAT AND AGAIN I
HAVE TREMENDOUS RESPECT AND
GRATITUDE TO ALL OF YOU HAVE
SERVED OUR COUNTRY- I WAS ON THE
MILITARY BUT ACTUALLY DOES WANT
TO OTHER- COMMISSION COURTS THAT
NON MILITARY IT WAS. ACTUALLY AN
OFFICER IN THE US PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICE COMMISSIONED CORPS. AND
I TOOK THE OATH THE SAME BOTH.
JUST MY COUNTRY AS WELL TO
BECOME THE COMMISSION OFFICER IN
THE US PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICE
COMMISSIONED CORPS AND WE ALSO
BY THE WAY TOOK A SIMILAR OF
WHEN WE'RE SWORN INTO OFFICE. SO
I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT- YOU KNOW
THIS. THAT IF THERE'S A
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES- WASN'T
RAISED BY LET'S COUNCIL THE
SUPREME COURT HAS RULED VERY
CLEARLY THAT- THAT- WITH THAT WE
CAN PUT IN RULES TO KEEP SCHOOLS
SAFE BY THE WAY SCHOOLS ARE
PLENTY OF ROLES- TRAIT. SEND
YOUR KID TO THIS TO YOUR SCHOOL
SOMETIMES WITH VIOLATING YEAH
YOU KNOW THEY HAVE CLOTHING
STANDARDS. OF OTHER TYPES OF
STANDARDS AS WELL AND- WE DON'T-
DON'T CLAIM THAT THEIR TYRANTS
SOMETIMES WE- OBJECT TO THEM
THAT'S FINE THAT'S THAT'S PART
OF DEMOCRACY. BUT BUT I THINK
MOST OF THE KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE
ARE CERTAIN RULES THAT SCHOOL
STUDENTS PLACE TO AND FROM
SCHOOL STAY SAFE AND- MOST OF US
CAN UNDERSTAND THAT- BUT- AGAIN
WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT. OUR
CHILDREN. I THAT. WE KNOW WHAT'S
ON IN OUR SCHOOL. PARENTS WANT
TO KNOW IN ORDER KEEP THEM THEIR
CHILDREN'S. THEIR HOUSEHOLD
SAFE. SCHOOLS WANT TO BE SURE
THEY CAN STAY OPEN THEY NEED TO
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON. THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT WE'RE
DOING TESTING SO WE CAN KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE SCHOOLS
WHEN IT COMES TO COBIT. AND HELP
WITH WE CAN KEEP COVERED REALLY
LOW CASES THEN MAYBE WE DON'T
NEED TO DO MUCH TESTING AT ALL
ON THIS THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
THAT AS WELL. WITH THAT.
ESPECIALLY AFTER I VOTE AND
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR- YOUR YOUR- YOUR- COMMENTS
THANK YOU. OUR IS THERE A MOTION
. YOU DID SENATOR WINNER MOVED
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION MADAM
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL PAN HI CAN I AM
MELINDA'S NO WINDOWS NO EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ AND SALAS I
GREW NO PROOF NO FURTADO LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE LEE MON LIMÓN AYE ROTH
ROTH I'VE RUBIO. WIENER WIENER
HI. OKAY THANK THE LOCAL AREA
THAT BILL- SEVEN TWO AND IT'S ON
CALL TILL WE WILL MOVE ON AND
MOVE BACK TO. DR PANAS THE CHAIR
RIGHT THANK YOU VICE TERM
LENDERS FOR CARING RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO NOW GO BACK TO. OUR
FILE ORDER SO I THINK CENTER
EGGMAN. PLEASE YOUR BILL IS THE
NEXT UNDER YOUR RATES ARE SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB. TEN OH
THREE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
SECURE AND MEMBERS I AM HERE TO
PRESENT S. B. TEN OH THREE. AND
THIS BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A
VOLUNTARY FORTY HOUR TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE TRAINING PROGRAM
FOR VICTIMS ADVOCATES TO BETTER
ASSIST SURVIVORS. IN HEALING AND
RECOVERY. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH WOULD
BE DESIGNATED TO CERTIFY THIS
TRAINING THIS TRAINING THAT IS
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW PEOPLE IF
THEY WANT TO SERVE AS AN ADDICT
ADVOCATE- THERE'S A- THIRTY
MINUTE TRAINING THEY CAN TAKE ON
TRAUMA. HERE WHICH IS A
FRAMEWORK THAT HELPS ADVOCATES
RECOGNIZE. RESPOND TO SIGNS
SYMPTOMS AND RISK OF TRAUMA. AS
IT RELATES TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF VIOLENCE AND CRIME.
THIS EXISTING TRAINING FOCUSES
ON HOW THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM WORKS VICTIMS RIGHTS
VICTIMS RESTITUTION. AND OTHER
CRITICAL ASPECTS HOWEVER THERE
ARE ONLY ABOUT THIRTY MINUTES OF
TRAINING IN TRAUMA INFORMED KERR
ALONG WITH HIS EXISTING
CURRICULUM. I BELIEVE THAT
PROVIDING TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
IS ESSENTIAL TO AVOID RE
TRAUMATIZING. AND HELP OUR
SURVIVORS HEAL AND RECOVER
SOMETIMES VOLUNTEERS WITH THE
BEST INTENTIONS CAN CAN BE A
PART OF RE VICTIMIZING SOMEBODY
IF THEY ARE INTRODUCED TO A
DRAMATIC SITUATION OR IN A
SETTING. I REMEMBER WHEN SITTING
IN A- COUNCIL MEETING AND
SOMEONE COMING AND TESTIFYING
ABOUT THEIR ABUSE- CAN I BUY I
DIDN'T THINK IT WAS A SAFE PLACE
FOR THAT PERSON TO BE TALKING
ABOUT THAT. AND I AND I RESTART
AFTERWARDS THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PROVIDING THAT SUPPORT. KIND OF
QUESTION THEIR TRAINING AND
INVOLVEMENT BEFORE THAT. AND
WAS- SURPRISED AT THE LACK OF
IT- SO AS MUCH AS WE WANT TO
HELP PEOPLE AND WE WANT TO
UTILIZE VOLUNTEERS FOR THOSE
WHICH IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
PEOPLE SHOULD BE WELL INFORMED
AND TRAINED IN ORDER TO
RECOGNIZE SIGNS AND SYMPTOMS AND
TO BE ABLE TO MINIMIZE- THINGS
THAT COULD COME UP FOR PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED AND
VIOLATED SOME OF THOSE THINGS
ARE ESTABLISHING PHYSICAL
EMOTIONAL SAFETY FOR THEM.
BUILDING TRUST PROVIDING
SURVIVOR CENTERED EVIDENCE BASED
CARE ALLOWING FOR A TANAMI AND
SURVIVORS TRIED TO FIGHT THEIR
OWN NEEDS FOR HEALING. AND
PROVIDING SERVICES GROUNDED IN
THAT INTERSECTION ALITY
UNDERSTANDING THAT ONE SIZE
DOESN'T FIT ALL. AND DEPENDING
ON WHO'S WHO SOMEONE IS AND
THEIR CIRCUMSTANCE IN PLACE IN
LIFE THAT CAN LEAD TO- TO THEM
BEING TRIGGERED IN DIFFERENT
KINDS OF WAYS- SO MANY TIMES.
THE LEVEL OF THE TRUMP
EXPERIENCE PRIOR TO WORKING WITH
VICTIMS ADVOCATES CAN BE
EXTREME. AGAIN INCLUDING RAPE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE EVEN THE
MURDER. OF A LOVED ONE. SB TEN
OH THREE WILL ALLOW FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A SYSTEM OR OF
TRUSTED TRAINING THAT WILL NOT
BE REQUIRED BY THE STATE TO
SERVE IN THIS ROLE BUT IT MAY BE
REQUIRED BY DA'S OFFICES OR
OTHER EMPLOYERS. TO WE'RE NOT
GONNA SEE PEOPLE HAVE TO HAVE
THIS- BUT IF THERE IS A
DEPARTMENT A DA THE BILL BE ABLE
TO HAVE A TRAINING TO PROVIDE
FOR PEOPLE. OF THAT THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH HAS
APPROVED. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY. AND I BELIEVE THEY'RE
STILL HERE THEY MAY HAVE HAD TO
LEAVE BECAUSE OF THE- THE LINKS
OF THE WEIGHT BUT THEY'RE
PROBABLY BE AVAILABLE THEM BY
PHONE. HE GINA CASTRO RODRIGUEZ
FROM THE PROSECUTOR'S ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND I ALSO HAVE
SAN JOAQUIN. DISTRICT ATTORNEY
TWENTY FOR PURCELLS ARE. THANK
YOU THIS EGGMAN AND I BELIEVE
YES UNFORTUNATELY- TORY- RIVER
CELLS ARE THAT WILL BE JOINED BY
PHONE BECAUSE SHE HAD TO LEAVE
EARLIER BUT- MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON TO LINE- GINA CASTLE
RODRIGUEZ FROM THE PROSECUTOR'S
LINE CALIFORNIA TORY FERBER
CELLS ARE SENATE CAN DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES. OUR
MODERATOR LINES ARE OPEN OKAY.
ASSOCIATED PRESS FOR ROAD REGUS
AVAILABLE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DR JEANETTE CAPTURE
RODRIGUEZ I'M A CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST AND ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR OF PSYCHOLOGY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF. SOUTH FOR TEACH
TRAUMA AND VICTIMOLOGY I'M ALSO
THE DIRECTOR OF THE SURVIVOR
POLICY TRAINING AND RESOURCE
CENTER FOR THE PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE THE CALIFORNIA AND
PRIOR TO THIS POSITION I WOULD
BE CHEAPER BECAUSE SERVICES IN
THE FAMILIES OF THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE FOR SEVEN
YEARS. I'M HERE FOR YOU TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF F. B. ONE
ZERO ZERO THREE BY SENATOR
EGGMAN. CAN ADVOCATE FOR THE
ATTORNEY OFFICES A NON. ORDER
PROVIDES CRITICAL SERVICES
CAMPUS OUT OF THE VICTIMS OF
CRIME EVERY YEAR. TO HELP THEM
NAVIGATE THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM THE VICTIM COMPENSATION
PROGRAM AND ACCESS SERVICES TO
HELP THEM DEAL. WITH ADVOCATES
ENGAGE WITH CRIME SURVIVORS HAVE
EXPERIENCED VIOLENCE RADICAL
THAT. UNFORTUNATELY THE CURRENT
TRAINING PROGRAM FOR THE VICTIM
ADVOCATES DO NOT PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT TRAINING IN TRAUMA
INFORMED KERR. TRAUMA INFORMED
KERR IS ABOUT UNDERSTANDING THE
RANGE OF SYMPTOMS AND REACTIONS
FROM OUT TO TRAUMA THAT PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE. IN WHEN THEY
EXPERIENCED VIOLENCE AND HARM
AND USING THAT KNOWLEDGE TO
FRAME THE WAY WE RESPOND IN IRAQ
AND INCREASE ENGAGEMENT TREAT
PEOPLE WITH TRAUMA. WITHOUT
ADEQUATE TRAINING IN TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE PROVIDERS CAN BE
FURTHER HARMS IN MY RECENT
RESEARCH STUDY SURVIVORS VOICES
WHICH- HAD BEEN GOING TO THE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
SURVIVORS. OF VIOLENT CRIME.
THEY OFFICE THEM ABOUT THE
NEGATIVE AND THEY HAD WITH AND
SERVICE WHO DID NOT HOW HELP
WORK WITH SURVIVOR HAD A HELL
THEM WHAT THE NEED AFTER. AND
HOW TO PROVIDE SUPPORT A DIRECT
. IF ARE NOT FULLY EQUIPPED TO.
OR RESPOND TO THE SIGN OF TRAUMA
. LEAVES SIX OF FEELING ON. AT
UNWILLING TO ENGAGE IN SERVICE
EIGHTY. SB ONE ZERO ZERO THREE
WILL ADDRESS THE ISSUES BY
SAVAGE SEVENTEEN A VOLUNTARY
FORTY HOUR TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
TRAINING PROGRAM. AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. RAINING WILL PUT THE
THAT TO RECOGNIZE THE SIGNS
SYMPTOMS CHRONIC. BUILD TRUST
AND ESTABLISH EMOTIONAL SAFETY
WOULD TAKE THEM AND PROVIDE CARE
THAT. BONTA TO THE PATIENT
GENDER RACIAL ETHNIC AND
CULTURAL ABOUT IDENTITY.
RESULTING IN BETTER HEALING
OUTCOMES FOR VICTIMS THE
COMMUNITY. I'M THANKFUL TO
SENATOR EGGMAN FOR INTRODUCING
THIS BILL AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THOSE. ON SB ONE EIGHT ZERO ZERO
THREE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
BALLOT SO BRING ON TORY VERBAS
ARE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CELLS ARE IN A PROSECUTOR FOR
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS TWENTY
FIFTEEN I HAD THE HONOR OF
SERVING AS A DISTRICT ATTORNEY
FOR SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY. I'M HERE
TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB
ONE ZERO ZERO THREE BY SENATOR
EIGHT- THAT WILL STOP AS LONG
CARRY TRAINING PROGRAMS VICTIM
ADVOCATES. IN TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE. BEING A PROSECUTOR IS A
TREMENDOUS RESPONSIBILITY BUT
IT'S ALSO ABOUT HEALING THE
COMMUNITIES WHEN. DRESSING
TRAUMA AND ALTERNATELY
PREVENTING YOU FROM US IN THE
COMMEMORATION FROM OCCURRING IN
THE FIRST PLACE. OUR VICTIM
ADVOCATES ARE CRITICAL TO THE
PRODUCT THAT. THEY HELP MAKE
VICTIMS EXPERIENCES WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM MUST
DRAMATIC IN EASIER TO UNDERSTAND
INCLUDING ASSISTING THEM DURING
INVESTIGATIONS AND COURT
PROCEEDINGS. AND HELPING THEM
FILE CREATED FOR VICTIM
COMPENSATION. BUT PARTLY THEY
PROVIDE HOPE IN HEALING DAN
HOW'RE VICTIMS IN THE RECOVERY
FROM CRISIS TO CRISIS
INTERVENTION IN OTHER SUPPORT
SERVICES. HOWEVER WHAT WE HAVE
FOUND THROUGH OUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE VICTIMS AND WITH
ADVOCATES THEMSELVES. IS THAT
THE CURRENT TRAINING FOR IT
LACKS. OKAY I TRUMP FORM. H.
MANY ADVOCATES BELIEVE THEY
WOULD BE BETTER EQUIPPED TO DO
VACANCY REPORTER PRACTICALITY IF
THEY HAD ADDITIONAL INDUSTRY.
SPECIFICALLY IN THIS AREA.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL AIMS TO
GIVE YOU PROVIDE OF ALL OF INTO
TRAINING PROGRAM. ARE COMMON FOR
CARE FOR ABBY ONE TO ATTAIN THE
NEXT LEVEL OF SERVICE MAKING.
THEY YOU SENATOR EGGMAN AND THE
COMMITTEE CREATED YOU CAN TO
FILL I BEFORE AND I. SB ONE ZERO
ZERO. THANK YOU I THINK THAT THE
WITNESS NOW WITH ON OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
THREE HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
HUNDRED. FOUR HUNDRED- STOP.
OKAY SOME OF THE- THEY MORTGAGE
POSITION PLEASE. HI MY NAME IS
AVERY HULAGU'S SENTIMENTALLY
HERE FOR MYSELF. AND I DO
SUPPORT THIS BILL OKAY AND I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY SEE NO ONE ELSE
COMING UP BEFORE THE MICROPHONE-
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHICH A TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT AND S. B. TEN. OH
THREE. WHICH SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. ONE ZERO ZERO. ONE. AND
WITH THE REAGIERT TIMES. MOBILE
YEAH A NUMBER. BIRADARI HAVE
TROUBLE HEARING YOU. ANYONE ON
THE LINE. OKAY YOU HAVE A FUTURE
YEAH. WE'LL START WITH ONE THREE
THREE S. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
A SOUND BUT THEY'RE GOING TO
DIRECTOR STATE POLICY OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE ZERO ZERO
THREE IN A CREATURE I THOUGHT
AND STILL THINK YOU THANK YOUR
NEXT WITNESS. BACK TO A. THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU THE
GRAMMAR SHE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRETORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE. THREE ONE. HELLO MY
NAME IS LAURA GREGORY AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB. ONE
ZERO ZERO THREE I THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THAT'S GOING TO REACH
WELL AS- ATTENTION TURN TO HAVE
A BUT PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT I THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THE FOURTEENTH.
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN. I EVEN WITH
THE FEINBERG INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
SHARE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
HUMAN RIGHTS THANK YOU LET'S NOW
MOVE ONTO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WITH NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION REGISTERED FOR
TESTIMONY IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO TEN OH
THREE SAINTONGE MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES TO ANY WITNESSES
WHO WOULD TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB TEN OH THREE YEAH NAME
POSITION AND TEAM WORK THIS
POSITION ONLY. AND WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF THE ONE ZERO
ZERO THREE. PRESS ONE YOU WERE
THE TIME. YOU HAVE ONE IN JUNE
AT. ONE FIFTY NINE. I AM SORRY
I'M ACTUALLY CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. ONE ZERO ZERO THREE MY
NAME IS JONATHAN GO I'M WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE
ARE A STRONG SUPPORT SB NINE
ZERO ZERO THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. ANYWAY THIS IS
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE NO NO
COMPUTER TRIBE EXCELLENCE BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE I LIKE TO
MONTH IT'S BEEN. A ROUGH OKAY
ANY ANY OTHER COMMENTS BUT I
JUST WANTED TO MOVE THE BILL
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SEE SEE
NONE- OKAY- TYREESE OF SPAGHETTI
ARE EGGMAN YOU SO MUCH BEING
SLOW FOR- AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE- THE IMPORTANCE OF
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO- WHICH
LIKE CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I WILL NOT TAKE YOUR LACK OF
CONVERSATION AS LACK OF SUPPORT
FOR MY BILL BUT- LACKS SUPPORT
FOR US ALL TO HAVE A BIT MORE
TIME- YET THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS AND
I JUST WANNA. ALSO SAY THIS IS.
FOR THE VICTIMS. IN ORDER TO
HEAL PROPERLY BUT THIS IS ALSO
GOOD FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
VOLUNTEERS. TO BE ABLE TO GET
THIS ADDITIONAL TRAINING TO FEEL
MORE CONFIDENT WHAT THEY DO AND
THEN HOPEFULLY GO ON EVEN BECOME
PART OF OUR LARGER BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEM I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS OKAY THANK YOU CENTER
EGGMAN- SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE FIRST. BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS AND
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SERA- SIX-
CONSOLE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL HIM
HI CAN I AM MELINDA'S MELINDA'S
I EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROW. HER LEYVA.
LEYVA I. FROTH LIFE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE WIENER AYE
WIENER AYE OKAY SO THAT BILLS
CURRENTLY EIGHT ZERO I WILL PUT
THE BILL ON- ON CALL BEFORE YOU
MOVE ON I KNOW CENTER ROUGH AND
EASILY SO I'M IF I WOULD LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CITY OKAY IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SAMMELAN DOESN'T
AGAIN EXCEPT CALENDARS ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB NINE THIRTY FOUR
OF US AND RUBIO I'M NUMBER FOUR
SB NINE SIXTY SEVEN BY CENTER
HERTZBERG AS AMENDED. AND ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
THREE BISON FAN MYSELF IT'S BEEN
MOVE I SERVED- MELINDA'S-
CONTROL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR PAN RIGHT
HAND BY MELINDA'S MELINDA'S I
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE AND SALAS
GONZALEZ I GROWTH FURTADO LEYVA. LEYVA HIGHLY MON. ROTH ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE WIENER
WIENER AYE OKAY. CALENDARS
FINALLY EIGHT ZERO BUT THE STAFF
TO AND CALENDAR ON CALLS. WITH
THAT LET'S MOVE ON THE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
FOUR CENTER EGGMAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SB ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR
WOULD REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH
IN CONSULTATION WITH OTHER
RELEVANT DEPARTMENTS TO
ESTABLISH A DATABASE FOR
PSYCHIATRIC. SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER AND OTHER COMMUNITY
MENTAL HEALTH BEDS I DELETE THIS
DATABASE WOULD BE. UPDATED AND
MAINTAINED AS CHANGES IN
AVAILABILITY OCCUR IN ORDER TO
STREAMLINE COMMUNICATIONS AND
REDUCE WAITING TIME FOR
PLACEMENTS OR APPROPRIATE BEDS.
I HAVE A LOT OF TALKING POINTS I
WILL JUST SAY WE ARE STILL DOING
IT LIKE WE DID WHEN I WAS FIFTY
ONE FIFTEEN PEOPLE WAY BACK IN
THE EIGHTIES YOU GOT A PIECE OF
PAPER YOU'RE LOOKING AT WHO'S
GOT A BAD AND YOU'RE TRYING TO
CALL AROUND. TO PLAY SOMEBODY IT
MAKES TIMES IN OUR E. OURS TAKE
FOREVER IT MAKES PEOPLE SPEND
WAY TOO MUCH TIME NOT GETTING
THE TREATMENT THEY NEED WE DON'T
KNOW WHERE THE BEDS ARE WHERE
WHERE THERE IS ONE OPEN- TO THIS
WILL AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT CAN
BE COMPLICATIONS WITH US WE'VE
BEEN PUTTING THIS BILL SINCE
TWENTY SIXTEEN. AT THE TIME IT
WAS FEDERAL FUNDING FOR IT THERE
IS NOT NOW- I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS THIS
DOESN'T EVEN JUST GET PEOPLE
STABILIZED BUT THEN ALSO LETS US
KNOW WHERE THE STEP DOWNS ARE SO
THAT TEY CAN AND MOVE THROUGH
OUR SYSTEM IT IS RIDICULOUS FOR
US IN CALIFORNIA. THE HOBBIT OF
TECHNOLOGY NOT TO HAVE MY
DATABASE THAT WE KNOW WHAT THAT
IS OPEN IS IT FOR SUICIDAL
TWENTY THREE YEAR OLD HOMELESS.
TRANSGENDERED WOMAN OR WHO IS IT
FOR AND WHAT IS THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF CARE. THAT WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO HAVE THAT ONLINE AND AN
UPDATED- WITH ME IN SUPPORT
TODAY I HAVE THE VERY PATIENT
WHO HAS WAITED VERY LONG MAYOR
FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY. A
PATRICIA LOCK DAWSON. I ALSO
HAVE DR CAMERON ONE BACK MEDICAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE COURT DOES. IS
A MENTAL HEALTH FACILITY ON THE
PHONE LINE AFTER YOU CAN TAKE IT
THIS SHOULD BE TAKEN THAT ORDER
. THE MAYOR'S HERE OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO MAYOR AT PATRICK CO
AUTHOR. WELCOME AND THE A TWO
MINUTE. HE THANK YOU IT'S
PATRICIA THEY'LL SURPRISE US
OKAY WELL GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN PAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PATRICIA
LOCK DAWSON I HAVE THE HONOR OF
SERVING AS THE MAYOR OF THE CITY
OF RIVERSIDE THE TWELFTH LARGEST
CITY IN THE STATE AND THE
LARGEST CITY IN INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTY SEAT. AND ONE
WHO IS STRUGGLING WITH TRYING TO
GET SERVICES TO THE PEOPLE THAT
CENTER EGGMAN IS REFERRING TO
I'D BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T TAKE
THE TIME TO PUBLIC THANK MY
SENATOR CENTER RAFA FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND SERVICE TO OUR
COUNTRY AND COMMUNITY. I'M HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
AND FIFTY FOUR. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY BIG CITY MAYORS
REPRESENTING THIRTEEN LARGEST
CITIES IN THE STATE OF WHICH I'M
A PART. AND IT'S OFFICIALLY
SUPPORTED BY THE INLAND EMPIRE
COALITION OF MAYORS A BIPARTISAN
COALITION OF NINE MAYORS FROM
STAMINA DINO IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
. AS A THREE TIME GUBERNATORIAL
APPOINTEE TO THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES
UNDER BROWN AND SCHWARZENEGGER.
AND FORMER VICE CHAIR OF THAT
BOARD I HAVE FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE IN SETTING
COMMUNICATING AND ENFORCING
STANDARDS FOR SAFE AND COMPETENT
DELIVERY OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. AS YOU NO PROMPT
ACCESS TO CARE IS OFTEN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN AN INDIVIDUAL
SLEEP CENTER STREET OR SLEEPING
IN A BED. AND OVER THE COURSE OF
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE A
TOTAL OF A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE BEDS ARE AVAILABLE AT THAT
RIVERSIDE EMERGENCY SHELTER
FAMILY SHELTER IN RECUPERATIVE
CARE PROGRAM. WITH FIFTY OR NEW
BEDS CREATED ARE HOMELESS
SERVICE CAMPUS. BED REGISTRIES
ARE AN ESSENTIAL TOOL. CENTRAL%
TO ALL TO SPEED ACCESS TO CARE
AND PROVIDE TIMELY COORDINATION
BETWEEN SERVICE SETTINGS. SB
ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR WILL ELIMINATE
DATA SILOS. TO ALLOW FOR AGENCY
COLLABORATION AND ACCESS TO
PROMOTE APPROPRIATE TRANSFER TO
SERVICES FOR THOSE SUFFERING
FROM CRITICAL NEED AND THOSE IN
CRISIS. SO I PLEASE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY OF S. B. O. M.
FIFTY FOUR AS THE LEGISLATION
STRENGTHENS THE ABILITY OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ASSIST
INDIVIDUALS WITH DRUG ADDICTION
AND OR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND I APPRECIATE ALL THAT YOU
ARE DOING CENTER EGGMAN. RIGHT
THANK YOU YOUR HONOR- THAT WILL
HELP BRING ONTO THE LINE- CAMP
DR CAMERON. BACK- WITH CORDLESS
MENTAL HEALTH FACILITY. PLEASE
BEGIN. SECTOR CONTACT AVAILABLE. CONTACT. BYRIDER BY REUTERS IS
DOCTOR QUAN BACK AVAILABLE. WE
LOST EVERYBODY MORRELL BY WRITER
. HI I'M HERE I'M NOT SEEING HIM
ON THE LINE. OKAY ALL RIGHT-
WELL MAYBE WE'LL- BE ABLE TO DO
THIS ONE COMES ON THE LINE LET
ME KNOW BUT WE'LL JUST GO AHEAD
AND GO AHEAD AND CONTINUE HERE-
SO WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. LIN FIFTY FOUR HERE IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. SAY NO ONE
COMING UP TO THE MICROPHONE AND
EFFECTIVE CONTACTS NOT AVAILABLE
LET'S JUST GO OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT. THIS BILL IN FIFTY FOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT
THIS TIME. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE. THREE TWENTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS CALLS
FOR US WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MEXICO ONE THREE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR THE MEMBERS TO MADDEN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANKS WITH
THIS. BUYING THREE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CARRYING MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MATURE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION AT THE FOR UP. TO
FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE THREE
NINETY TWO THE THREAT FOR.
GERMAN MEMBERS PLAYER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION PSYCHIATRIST PROUD
CO SPONSOR OF THE- BILL PACKAGE-
DR- THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. AN EXCELLENT
ONLINE THREE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MA'AM AT THE
FEINBERG INSTITUTE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU EXPERTNESS.
ONE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RANDALL HEY YOU'RE
REPRESENTING THE PSYCHIATRIC
PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THE EIGHT BILL
PACKAGE THANK YOU THANK YOU
EXCELENTES. MEXICO WINDS THREE
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO JONATHAN GO NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER CALLING
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN
FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH I
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. MEXICO
LINE FORTY NINE WE SHOULD. I
FORTY NINE ONE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
MAYBE NEXT WITNESS THEN- THERE'S
NO NOTHING TO AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THANKS FOR MUCH ILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THAT FEELING FIFTY
FOUR WE HAVE NO FORMAL
REGISTERED OPPOSITION FOR
TESTIMONY. WELL THEN- OPEN UP
FOR OPPOSITION TO ESTIMATES IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED SAYING ONLY
COME AT THE MICROPHONE. BYRIDER
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
ANY WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN FIFTY
FOUR. I CAN SEE THAT WE HAVE
YOUR- THE SPEAKER- OKAY ALL
RIGHT- SO THIS- TACTIC ONE BACKS
RELIABLE- WE WILL ALLOW THEM AT
THE EXEMPTS- CONTACT 22% SO YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. HI I'M I'M
CAME HOME BACK FROM A FORENSIC
PSYCHIATRIST AND MEDICAL
DIRECTOR WORKING FOR SAN MATTEO
COUNTY HEALTH. MY COLLEAGUES MY
WORKING IN OUR PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCY ROOM SIX THIS DATABASE
IS A HUGE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. MOST NOVEL ELEMENT IS
THAT IT WILL BE UPDATED IN REAL
TIME TO REFLECT BETTER
AVAILABILITY. CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATION PSYCHIATRIC UNIT
IS FULL IN APPRECIATION TO BE
SENT TO AN OUTSIDE HOSPITAL. A
NURSE WORKS WITH A LIST OF
HOSPITALS IN CONTACT NUMBERS AND
SPENDS THE NEXT TWENTY FOUR TO
FORTY EIGHT HOURS MAKING PHONE
CALLS. SPEAKING MESSAGES AND FAX
RECORDS HOPING TO LOCATE A BAD.
OFTEN THE CONTRACT INFORMATION
IS INACCURATE IN THE STRUGGLE TO
REACH THE CORRECT PERSON A
POTENTIAL RECEIVING HOSPITAL.
CUMBERSOME INEFFICIENT PROCESS
THAT CONTRIBUTES TO STAFF
BURNOUT THIS DATABASE WILL HELP
. MY COLLEAGUES IN OUR PUBLIC
GUARDIAN'S OFFICE WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR FINDING LONG
TERM PLACEMENTS FOR PEOPLE ON
MENTAL HEALTH CONSERVATORSHIP.
WE'D FIFTY BED DATABASE WILL BE
VERY HELPFUL IN THEIR WORK AS
WELL. MANY OF THE CLIENTS HAVE
COMPLEX MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH NEEDS SUCH AS MOBILITY
IMPAIRMENT IN FLINT REQUIREMENTS
IN OTHER HEALTH CHALLENGES THAT
COME DIFFICULT TO PLACE SOME
SPEND MONTHS AND MONTHS IN THE
HOSPITAL WAITING FOR A BED AT A
LOWER LEVEL OF CARE. BUT STATE
OFFICIALS WOULD GIVE THEM THE
ABILITY TO CONDUCT LARGE SCALE
SEARCHES OF MANY FACILITIES
ACROSS A LARGE GEOGRAPHIC AREA
AND MORE QUICKLY IDENTIFY
PLACEMENTS TABLE TO ACCOMMODATE.
THE HEALTH NEEDS OF THEIR
CLIENTS. ACCORDING TO THIS
PROPOSAL BAD DATABASE WILL
IMPROVE THE CARE IN MY COUNTY
AND WILL BENEFIT SMALLER
HOSPITALS AND UNDERSERVED
COUNTIES EVEN MORE. THE SUMMER
OF UBER OR LIFT RIDE WITHIN
MINUTES WHY CAN'T WE USE
INTERNET BASED TECHNOLOGY TO
FIND TO FIND A METHOD MENTAL
HEALTH THAT. THE FACT WILL BE
THE ABILITY TO CONNECT PEOPLE TO
THE RIGHT CARE AT THE RIGHT
INTENSITY AT THE RIGHT TIME. IN
ADDITION LIKE THIS IS LONG
OVERDUE IN CALIFORNIA'S MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM BUT SHORTEN THE
WAY. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
RIGHT NOW- MODERATOR DEFERRED
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES ANY
WITNESSES WHO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN FIFTY
FOUR. THANK YOU WHICH SPEAK NOT
POSITION OF AT ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR
THE FIRST ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. SMALL WE HAVE SOMEBODY
JUNIOR.
OKAY AND. ONE THREE BEFORE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI I WOULD
HAVE IT ON MUTE SO I COULDN'T
SPEAK SO I JUST WANTED TO SAY I
AM FOR THIS. PLEASE ENTER YOUR
NAME PLEASE SIGN HAVE. OH SORRY
MY NAME IS- BENDABLE PARENTS
FROM SAN MATTEO. AND YOUR AND
LET BRANDIS. OKAY AT SEND THAT
CENTER PROPRIOCEPTIVE CASELLA
LAZIM DID YOU SAID YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR ALL
RIGHT OKAY NEXT WITNESS WE'RE
TAKING WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO SB ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR. IN THIS
YEAR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'VE ACTIVE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS. FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER ROUGH. ASSEMBLY
LONDIS. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
JUST- I. FULLY SUPPORT YOUR BILL
BUT I DID HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT- I KNOW EVEN MORE THAN
THIS ONE BUT THE COSTS THAT MAY
BE ASSOCIATED WITH BUILDING A
SYSTEM LIKE THIS WHICH WOULD BE
VAST IMMUNITY YOU KNOW STATE OF
FORTY MILLION. AND THEN THE
ANALYSES ARE YOU KNOW KIND OF
HOW WE'VE LOOKED AT OTHER STATES
HAVE TRIED TO DO THIS AND THE
INABILITY TO REALLY KEEP IT YOU
KNOW TWENTY FOUR SEVEN UP TODAY
IT'S NO SMALL TASK AND I JUST
WONDER. IF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS
ON THAT I DO I DO WE ARE
CURRENTLY AND OVER THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS SPENDING BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS WERE SENDING DOWN TO
STREAMLINE OUR MENTAL HEALTH AND
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SYSTEM- TWENTY
THREE STATES ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON ASSEMBLY NOBODY HAS
BEEN ABLE TO BE FULLY SUCCESSFUL
AT THIS. BUT WE BELIEVE THERE
HAS BEEN ENOUGH STARTS AND STOPS
THAT WE KNOW WHAT WE NEED IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO DO IT DONE
TO GET IT DONE AND WE ARE ALSO
WORKING- IN. WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO BE ABLE TO GET
ALL THE INFORMATION BECAUSE OF
COURSE SOME HAVE YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT PEOPLE HAVE DIFFERENT
ISSUES WITH THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME WE'VE HAD NO OPPOSITION
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN WORKING. VERY
IN A VERY INTEGRATIVE
COLLABORATIVE WAY TO BE ABLE TO
GET THIS DONE- AND SO YOU'RE
RIGHT BECAUSE OF THE COMPLEXITY
OF OUR OF OUR SYSTEM- WHICH I
JUST. THIS UNDERSTOOD THE IDEA
THAT WE NEED THIS EVEN MORE
BECAUSE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
LOOKING AT LIKE TIME FOR ALL THE
PLACEMENT HOW LONG DOES THAT
TAKE HOW LONG SOMEBODY WAITING
IN AN EMERGENCY ROOM AND THEN
WHAT PART OF THE STATE IS THAT
HAPPENING AND WHERE IT'S NOT
BECAUSE THAT WILL TELL US ABOUT
RESOURCES. SINCE THE PLACEMENT
BUT WE'VE HURDLE BUT THIS ME ME
. B. AND SAM. COUNTY THERE'S NO
BREAD FOR NATALIE. PER SO THEY
HAVE TO GET THREE SPENT THREE OR
FOUR COUNTIES OVER. HUGE
PROBLEMS RIGHT AND THEN WE CAN
BETTER DIRECT OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
DOLLARS. THAT WE'RE ALSO
CURRENTLY HAVING BILLIONS GO
DOWN FOR TO BE ABLE TO FIND-
DIVERSION FROM INPATIENT
SETTINGS TO CRISIS STABILIZATION
UNITS RIGHT. HOW ARE THOSE
THINGS GOING ON BECAUSE WE KNOW
WE- THERE'S- ALL THESE DIFFERENT
LEVELS. SO IS A COMPLEX YES OF
COURSE IT IS. IS IT NECESSARY
AND WILL STREAMLINE OUR SYSTEM.
I THINK WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
EXPERTS THAT THEY THINK IT IS-
WE AGAIN. I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
WORK FOR A LONG TIME. IT IS IT
IN MY MIND- OUTRAGEOUS THAT
WE'RE STILL USING THE SAME
TECHNOLOGY AND HAVE THE SAME
PEOPLE WITH. LICENSE MAKING
CALLS. ON THE TELEPHONE FROM A
NOTEBOOK- TO TRY TO FIND A BED
FOR SOMEBODY. WHILE EVERYBODY
ELSE IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM. IS
SITTING WITH SOMEBODY WHO IS. A
MEDICATED AND UNTREATED AS THEY
CONTINUE. TO EXAGGERATE. SO IS
IT COMPLEX YES IT IS. SO- THE
AND THE PERSONAL SERVICE THAT
WE'VE BECAUSE WE'VE DOES NOT THE
FIRST TIME THAT HAS ONLY BEEN IN
THE MILLIONS NOT BILLIONS OKAY
SO I'M JUST WONDERING IF SINCE
OTHER STATES HAVE TRIED THIS-
THE SOFTWARE EXIST THOUGH IT
COULD BE IMPROVED IS THAT A
CONSIDERATION THAT YOU WOULD DE
YOU KNOW SORT OF BORROW THAT OR
IT IS THERE. I DON'T KNOW THE
NOTION THAT SILICON VALLEY COULD
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW HELP WITH THIS
AND DEVELOP SOMETHING BECAUSE I
JUST THINK IF THE DM B. IF YOU
CAN ON THE DMV'S WEBSITE AND
SCHEDULE AN APPOINTMENT ANYWHERE
IN THE STATE ANY DMB FOR
DRIVER'S LICENSE TEST OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT SURELY THERE
IS THE ABILITY TO DO SOMETHING
LIKE THIS. YOU KNOW. RIGHT OKAY
WELL. POSTMASTER THE OBVIOUS
HERE THANK YOU. WITH ONE OF THE
DIFFICULTIES IN JUST TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT IS BECAUSE WE'RE
DEALING WITH COULD BE STATE
AGENCIES COULD BE COUNTY
AGENCIES COULD BE NONPROFITS
SOME OF THE STEP DOWN UNITS SO
IT'S NOT JUST DIEM VS JUST ALL.
IN A STATE DATABASE SO THIS IS
THIS IS GOING TO NEED TO MERGE
DIFFERENT DATABASES THANK YOU. I
FEDERAL. THANK YOU I HAVE I
THINK IT'S RIGHT TO THINK ABOUT
THE ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH IT
PROJECTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE CERTAINLY
DEMONSTRATED THAT OVER THE LAST
TEN TO TWELVE YEARS BUT- HAVING-
BEEN A MEMBER OF VARIOUS
HOSPITAL BOARDS- DURING MY TIME.
ON THIS EARTH PRIOR TO COMING UP
HERE TO SACRAMENTO AND-
EXPERIENCING THE DIFFICULTY WITH
THE FIFTY ONE FIFTIES. OF
FRANKLY FLOODING THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS- OF STANDING IN
CORNERS HAVING TO BE MONITORED.
FOR THE OF SEVENTY TWO HOURS
THAT- FOR THE COULD BE HELD IN
THOSE DEPARTMENTS I THINK WE
ALSO HAVE TO WEIGH THE COST.
OVERALL CUSTOMER HEALTH SYSTEM
OF HAVING TO IN ESSENCE WERE
HOUSE. THOSE WHO REALLY DESERVE
TO BE IN LICENSED PSYCHIATRIC
TREATMENT FACILITIES WEIGH THE
COST OF THAT TO OUR HOSPITAL
SYSTEM IN EVALUATING THE VALUE.
THE VALUE- ELEMENTS HERE TO THIS
TO THIS PROPOSAL SO I FULLY
FULLY SUPPORT IT. OKAY THANK YOU
FOR ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SIR EDMUND- I
PREFER YOU BRING THIS BILL FORD
I THINK- SOME CHANNELS EIGHT
AND- CENTERED MELINDA'S BROUGHT
UP NOT THE IN TERMS OF- YEAH
OTHER STATES HAVE TRIED TO SEND
WORKS SO WELL TO ME SOME OF IT
IS SAYING TO PROVIDE
EXPECTATIONS SO I HAVE TO MAY I
GET A LITTLE NERVOUS AND I SAID
WELL WE HAVE UBER AND LIFT AND
SO IT'S NOT GONNA BE. WE NOW
HAVE A DATABASE FOR SOMEONE SO
ON THINGS THAT YOU CAN FIND
SOMETHING BUT AS YOU POINTED
OUT. PERHAPS JUST HAVING
ACCURATE INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
KIND OF BEDS THEY HAVE. WHO YOU
KNOW WHAT THE FACTORED WAY TO
CONTACT HIS THE POINT PERSON FOR
A PERSON EVEN THAT ALONE IN A
DATABASE THAT'S GOOD THAT'S
MAINTAIN WOULD BE HIS READING
CORRECT RIGHT SO I DO WANT TO
SERVE. THREE YEAR OF THE
EXPECTATIONS IN TERMS OF LIKE-
WE HAVE A DATABASE SO I KNOW
EXACTLY HOW MANY EMPTY BEDS ARE
RIGHT NOW AND THAT'S COULD BE
TOTALLY ACCURATE BUT STILL.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN ALL THE TIME.
BECAUSE I THINK WE MAY. WE BE ON
THE TAX. RIGHT BUT I JUST WANT
TO. CONTINUE TO. ON MOVING THIS
BILL FORWARD I THINK THIS YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
PROPOSES. IS AN EXCELLENT IDEA I
HOPE I DO HOPE THAT. IN THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE SCALE BACK
EXPECTATIONS MAYBE WE CAN MEET
THOSE EXPECTATIONS GREAT BUT-
DON'T BE LOW CLASSES ABOUT THAT
THE WITH THAT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
THINK WE SHOULD SET HIGH
EXPECTATIONS FOR OURSELVES. AND
I WILL SAY. HISTORICALLY THE
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN
OPPOSED TO THIS. NOT SO MUCH
ANYMORE JUST BECAUSE OF THE
IMPACT ON ON THEM. HAS COME TO
THE POINT WHERE. EVERYONE
ACKNOWLEDGES. THAT WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS NOT WORKING AND WE NEED
TO DO IT. BETTER FOR ALL OF US.
I'M PEOPLE HEARD ME TALK ABOUT.
THAT MY A BILL PACKAGE AT MANY
OF YOUR CO AUTHORS ON. THIS IS A
KEY PIECE IN IT AND BEING ABLE
TO STREAMLINE. BECAUSE AGAIN. WE
KNOW THAT A LOT OF FOLKS ARE
GOING TO COME INTO THE SYSTEM IF
THEY'RE NOT MEDICATED THEY'RE
GONNA BE. BACK IN. WITHIN THE
NEXT TWENTY FOUR HOURS. OR
COMMIT A CRIME AND END UP IN OUR
JAIL SYSTEM. ALL OF THOSE ARE
NOT. IS NOT THE HUMANE WAY TO GO
ABOUT TREATING PEOPLE OR THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE FOR
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR EITHER. THANK YOU CENTER
EGGMAN- SO THE MOTIONS TO PASS
THE- FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS MOVE BY
CENTER ROCKED- CONSULT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CAN I CAN HI
MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I GONZALEZ. CONSULT BOTH.
PROTECT HIGH POTATO AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA BY. LEE MON. ROTH ALL
RIGHT. ROTH IRA RUBY. RUBIO
WIENER. WIENER AYE. OKAY THE
NICE OKAY SO THE BILL'S
CURRENTLY NOW ZERO- WILL PUT THE
BILL ON CALL FOR NUMBER ALL
RIGHT- WITH SO MOVE TO SB TEN
EIGHTY NINE BY SO WILKINS
MELENDEZ WILL BE PRESENTING-
AND- BUT INSTEAD WELCOME. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND GOOD AFTERNOON ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR WILK I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB TEN EIGHTY
NINE BUT FIRST LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS TO THIS
BILL THIS IS A STRAIGHT FORWARD
BILL ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES WHO WERE
ABLE TO RECEIVE THE HIGHEST
QUALITY EYEGLASSES AVAILABLE
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES UP TOM
INTERESTED OTHER PROVIDERS TO
OBTAIN EYE GLASSES FROM AN
INDIVIDUAL AND MEDICARE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA. PRISON INDUSTRY
AUTHORITY UNFORTUNATELY THE
SYSTEM IS PLAGUED WITH PROBLEMS
AS THE EYE GLASSES OFTEN TAKE
MONTHS TO DELIVER TO PATIENTS
AND ARE SUCH POOR QUALITY IN IN
SOME CASES IT CAN CAUSE
IRRITATION OR THEY'RE LESS
DURABLE AND BREAK MORE EASILY
THAN AYE GLASSES MANUFACTURED
ELSEWHERE NUMEROUS STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE
SUFFERS FRIDGE. CAN'T SEE WELL
WITH PROPER CORRECTION AS NOTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA TIME
INTERESTED TO SEE ASIAN DIVISION
CARE CRISIS CAUSED BY KEVIN
NINETEEN HAS BROUGHT TO THIS
SPOTLIGHT THE FAILURE OF THE
SINGLE SUPPLIER POLICY SB TEN
EIGHTY NINE ADDRESSES THIS
CONCERN BY ALLOWING PROVIDERS TO
GO OUTSIDE OF THE P. I. A. TO
OBTAIN OUR GLASSES FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. TODAY WITH ME IS
TERRY MCHALE I'M REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA TOM TRICKS TO STATION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS RIGHT THANK YOU THIS
WILL HELP WELCOME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN TERRY MCHALE
WITH THEIR AND READ AN
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION. THE BILL IS VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD THE BILL A LOT
OF SUCCESSES IN THE PRISONS YOU
KNOW THE POPULATION MOVING. TENS
OF THOUSANDS. UNFORTUNATELY WITH
PI REMAIN. WITH US OF A MEMBERS.
OVER 50% OF THEM SAID IT TAKES
MORE THAN TWO MONTHS. TO GET THE
GLASSES 38% SAID IT TOOK MORE
THAN A MONTH- IT'S SUPPOSED TO
BE AN AVERAGE OF FIVE TO FIFTEEN%
DAYS- THE OPTION TO CONTINUE USE
THE PIAA WHERE TO SUCCESSFUL- IS
RETAINED IN THE BILL. I KNOW
YOU'VE HAD A LONG DAY I WANT TO
KEEP IT UNDER MY MINUTE AND HALF
AND- ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT
THANKS VERY MUCH- WITHOUT-
WELCOME WITNESS. OTHER
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF- S. B. TEN EIGHTY NINE NO
FIRST GOOD ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
SEEN ON COMEY AT THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHICH A TESTIFIED
IN SUPPORT. SB TEN EIGHTY NINE.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TEN EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE IN EUROPE THIS TIME.
MR WOULD HAVE KNOWN CHEWING UP
AT THIS TIME OKAY THANKS VERY
MUCH WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TEN EIGHTY NINE WE DO NOT HAVE
FORMAL REGISTERED OPPOSITION FOR
TESTIMONY SO WILL THEN GO FOR
DIGITAL WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
START WITH HEARING ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED SINGLE APPROACHING A
MICROPHONE. MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO
SHOULD TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB TEN EIGHTY NINE. AND HE WAS
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TEN EIGHTY
NINE THE FIRST. ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. HEY LET'S NOT
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY SAYING
NONE OF SO THURMOND AS I KNOW
THAT- TO PRESENT BEHALF THE
CENTER LOCUSTS AND BELIEVE THE
SURPRISED THE ADDRESS WHEN HE
GOES TO PUBLIC SAFETY BUT- I
THINK- YOU'LL CERTAINLY HEAR
HEALTH WE WON'T BE SURE PEOPLE
OF TIMELY ACCESS TO A QUALITY
EYEGLASSES. I THINK THERE ARE
SOME OTHER INTEREST IN TERMS OF-
YOU KNOW PI EIGHTY PARTICIPATING
IN TERMS OF PROVIDING THOSE
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES AND
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
HELP BUILD CAREER PATHS FOR.
PRISONERS WHO- FOR
REHABILITATION SO I THINK WHEN
WE WANT TO TRY A KNOWLEDGE OF
THAT ALTHOUGH I THINK IF I DEAL
WITH THOSE MORE THOSE ISSUES IN
THE NEXT COMMITTEE- SO HOPEFULLY
AGAIN- APPRECIATE. WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO WITH THE BILL I
THINK THE MESSAGE CENTER LOCUSTS
A HOPEFULLY WE CAN WORK OUT
SOMETHING TO ADDRESS- STILL BE
SURE THAT PA IF THEY CAN MEET
APPROPRIATE TIMELINESS AND
QUALITY STANDARDS THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT RIGHT AND THAT THAT'S
I KNOW THAT'S WHAT THE BILL'S BE
KERRY. THAT THAT THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO.
PROVIDE THIS. GLASS OBLIQUELY
SAID THAT WE CAN AGAINST A BILL
THAT RIVER. PATH FOR THEM IN THE
NEXT SEVERAL TO HOPEFULLY BE NO.
AND THE NEXT MAY. SO WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I WOULD
JUST VERY BRIEFLY I AIMS THAT
SO. WELL IN. TO ADDRESS THE CAN.
AND THEN COMMITTEE. ON WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS OKAY IS THERE A MOTION.
OKAY TO MOVE I CENTER LEYVA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED. AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE PUBLIC SAFETY-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PAN. AM ANA MELINDA'S I MELENDEZ
AYE EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HER TADO
MACHADO I LEYVA. AYE LEYVA AYE
LEE MON. LIMÓN AYE ROTH. RUBIO I
RUBIO AYE WIENER. WIENER HI.
OKAY THE BILL CURRENTLY HAS NINE
VOTES PUT THE BILL ON CALL ALL
RIGHT SO WITH THAT LET'S GO BACK
AND LIFT THE CALLS- ACTUALLY CAN
JUST TAKE ONE MOMENT.
ALL RIGHT. THE GROUP I'M NOT
SURE. OKAY COMMITTEE ON OKAY
LET'S- RIGHT SO- WE'LL JUST GO
FROM THE TOP FILE SO- WE HAVE. I
REMEMBER TO SB NINE SIXTY FOUR
BY CENTER WIENER- CONSOLE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THAT SOME MEMBERS
. HER TADO HURTADO I LEE MON
LIMÓN HI OKAY THAT BILL IS ABOUT
ELEVEN ZERO. ALL RIGHT NEXT ITEM
IS- ITEM NUMBER FIVE S. B. NINE
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE A CENTER HUESO
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS. HER TOP- FOR
TITLE I LIMON HI LIMON HI THAT
FILLS OUT ELEVEN ZERO- LET'S SEE
. WE HAVE ANYWAY- WELL NEXT BILL
IS- SB TEN TEN OH THREE BY
CENTER ADMIN CONSOLE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS GROW
HER TADO FURTADO I LIMON. IMAN I
OKAY SO THAT BILLS CREEK
CURRENTLY TEN ZERO HOLD THE BILL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB
ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR BY CENTER
EGGMAN CONSOLE PLEASE CALL
ROLLED ABSENT MEMBERS GROW. ME
MON. LIMON HI OKAY THAT BILLS
CURRENTLY TEN ZERO LEVEL WHOLE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
- NEXT ITEMS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SB TEN EIGHTY NINE BY CENTER
WILK I CANCELED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE ROTH
OKAY SO- WILL LOOK AT THAT
DIFFERENTLY NINE ZERO WILL KEEP
THAT ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS EXPECT AND I AND NUMBER
TEN SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE BY
CENTER PAN MYSELF- THE BILL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THAT SOME
MEMBERS. HER TADO HURTADO BY
RUBIO. RUBIO HI OKAY THAT BILL
IS ABOUT NINE TWO. RIGHT NOW WE
MOVE ON TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR-
SO BECAUSE OLD PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. GROVE
APARTADO. HURTADO I LIMON THANKS
A LOAN HI OKAY THAT CURRENT
DEVILS CURRENTLY TEN ZERO- WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. OKAY YEAH I KNOW. OKAY SO- SO BASICALLY- WE ARE
CONCLUDED THE WORD GEN HOWEVER
WE STILL HAVE BILLS ON CALL FOR
AT FOR AN ABSENT MEMBERS BUT
IT'S NOT EASIER SO LIKE SO THAT
YOU KNOW CASE YOU WANT TO LEAVE-
AND SO WILL WILL WAIT FOR THE
ABSENT NUMBER HERE. AND ACTUALLY
YOU KNOW WHAT I AM GOING TO THAN
RECESSED THE HEARING FOR RIGHT
NOW- AND- UNTIL THE OTHER ABSENT
MEMBERS APPEAR SELF. THE THIS IS
A HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH IS NOW
RECESSED.
WE ARE AT THREE THAT THE ENDING
THE RECESSES WERE RECALLING THE
ORDERED THIS HEARING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH.
LIFTING THE CALLS ON THE
REMAINING ITEMS. SIR- LET'S SEE
. SO CONSULTANTS THAT WILL BEGIN
WITH A NUMBER FIVE S. B. 988%
SO- CONSULTANTS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THAT THE MEMBERS. SHOULD WE
FINISH ON. SO THERE'S THAT ONE
OKAY THAT WAS AVAILABLE THAT'S
OUR SEX OKAY. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT SO THAT THAT'S
ACCURATE HOW TO LIVE ZERO. OKAY
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
TEN OH THREE BY CENTER EGGMAN
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS GROW I GROW BY
THAT BILLS OUT ELEVEN ZERO NEXT
IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. B.
ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR BY CENTER
EGGMAN. CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS CAN I
CORRECT THAT THAT'S ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN TEN EIGHTY NINE BY WILK-
NO I'VE RIGHT. THAT'S NUMBER
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. LET'S SEE
HAVE DIFFERENT ORDER WITH
DIFFERENT ORDER THAT'S OKAY
THOUGH. OKAY SO- UNDER ITS
CURRENT GENDER IS ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN IS SB ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. OKAY- CONSULT
THESE COLD ROLLED ABSENT MEMBERS
FOR OH FIVE GROVE I FACE UP
THOSE BELTS ELEVEN ZERO NEXT IS
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB TEN EIGHTY
NINE BY CENTER WILL. CONSULT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS GROW FIVE GROVE I ROTH.
OKAY THAT BILLS OUT TEN ZERO-
OKAY IN. FINALLY WE HAVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- SO CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. GROVE THANKS FOR OF I
PAY THIRTY DOLLARS OUT ELEVEN
OF. THE CASE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR YOU'RE WELCOME THANK YOU
SORRY ABOUT THE WAIT. ONCE. OKAY
SO AGAIN I WANT TO ASK ALL OF
THE PARTICIPANTS IN TODAY
HEARING- I THINK OUR WITH AND-
GOOD THANK THE STAFF IS AS
DEGREE ONE TO RECOGNIZE AND
THANK OTHERS- SENSE SERGEANTS
WHO HAD TO MANAGE A LITTLE BIT A
CROWD FOR WHAT THE- ITEMS SO
AGAIN APPRECIATE YOU MAINTAINING
AN ORDERLY HEARING ROOM AND WITH
THAT TO THIS CONCLUDES- THIS
AGENDA OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH- WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.